because they are easy but because they
are hard because that goal will serve to
organize and measure the best of our
energies and skills it's been 50 years
since we've been to the moon and we've
got a great program called Artemis we're
going back
the Apollo program was a test for the
American people that you can do what you
set out to do all it took was turning to
it and making it happen
we our goal for a mission to the moon at
this time
engines on five four three two
all engines running
commit liftoff we have liftoff 49
minutes past the hour
the characteristics system that I
remember most of the satisfy was the
noise the noise was enormous and it was
almost impossible to communicate
[Music]
we're going
Fair Quality Base here the eagle has
landed The Landing to me was a great
celebration the nation was almost
euphoric one small step for man
but try at least Amanda
there are so many things that we can
eventually learn about our universe and
the spacecraft that we use exploring
[Music]
we are a nation of explorers during a
pile up we were on national TV literally
every day because we were doing
something visible that America could see
and they could feel and say look what we
are doing and I believe Artemis is going
to come up and say look what we are
capable of and what we are doing now
[Music]
Artemis will stand on the shoulders of
Apollo they're going to have the eyes of
the world on them when they start down
this Trail
the science of a space flight is one
that will continue to inspire going to
the Moon generates technology more
Communications more computer technology
more sophistication in manufacturing
that help us in everyday life
we have a generation that is ready a
generation with that technology a
generation with the education armamus
represents a future in space it is our
next big step and it is time to take it
foreign
if you're just joining us welcome to
NASA's Kennedy Space Center where we are
showing you a live look of another
Visitor Center this is the U.S Space and
Rocket Center wow take a look at all of
those people who are there hoping to
watch the launch today you know this is
uh the visitor center for the Marshall
space flight center in Huntsville
Alabama they that Center played a
crucial role in contributing to the
Artemis program so I'm not I'm not a
surprised that there are a bunch of
people there watching
all right so now we're going to take a
uh go back to Leah Martin over at Banana
Creek again that's right outside of our
Visitor Center and she's with some other
folks who came out to watch today's
lunch
yeah you know Megan we talked about this
being America's rocket right every state
in the United States has contributed to
this rocket so it should be no surprise
that we have people from all over the
country joining us here tonight I'm
actually joined by uh some friends of
ours who are joining us from Georgia in
Utah what does it mean to be here
tonight to see tonight's launch I think
it's amazing I know that tons of people
from all over the United States have
helped build the rockets and are here
tonight so it's awesome to know that we
all have a little bit of personal ties
to the rocket
and go ahead no I'm just excited to be
here because I've been a fan of space
travel and going to the moon and back
and I'm glad to see it's happening again
later in life
and you were actually telling me a
little bit earlier that you grew up in
the Apollo era in those years following
those first launches and now here how
does it feel to be watching the sister
program launch and sing at the beginning
look at the Goosebumps that tells it all
right here I'm totally thrilled to be
here now and you were actually
there's a rocket as well you know some
people have worked on it what do you
think feels like being here how does it
feel for you to see something that's the
culmination of so many years of hard
work yeah I think it's crazy when you
think about how long it takes to build
it and stuff like I wasn't even born
last time people tried to get to the
moon so it's awesome I think it's so
exciting and I cannot wait
and uh we have a ton of people who are
working tonight still on Console we just
wanted to tell them words of
encouragement what more do you have to
say oh I hope this goes tonight
Megan back to you
go Artemis yes I love that and again I
just love these drone shots that we're
showing of all the people who are here
ready hoping uh anticipating uh launch
today so now let's head back over to Dan
so Dan is in the Apollo Saturn V Center
which is right next to uh This Crowd
that you're seeing here he's inside
there and he's going to tell us more
about SLS using an interactive
state-of-the-art tool we're calling the
moon board
that's right Megan and everybody Welcome
Back To The Moon board so just to recap
SLS out on the pad on the mobile
launcher Daryl's been walking you
through all of the tanking all the
preparation we had that hydrogen leak
that was in the base of the mobile
service structure here that's been
remedied we haven't had any issue with
those tail
umbilicals that we were tracking so
closely back in August uh and September
so everything looking really good with
SLS just to recap
most powerful rocket we have ever built
it's propelled by two solid rocket
boosters and four engines on this core
stage now these solid rocket boosters
are going to be firing for the first
roughly two minutes of the flight a
little more than two minutes and we call
them solids because of the type of
propellant in there if you forgot it
already it's aluminum powder ammonium
perchlorate and polybutadine
acrylonitrile it's a binding agent
that's inside solid propellants are
extremely stable they're very reliable
but once you ignite them they're going
to keep burning you can't really
throttle them up and down like you can
with liquid-fueled engines you can
throttle just based off of the
distribution so you basically put more
propellant in some areas and less in
others as you're trying to really
throttle the rocket down which we do as
we go through things like Max Q maximum
Dynamic pressure and just a reminder is
these things are firing they can steer
they can gimbal the bottom part here
gimbal just means you can really direct
and they're providing 90 percent of the
steering as SLS is making the flight
uphill and more than 75 percent of the
thrust with those two firing at the same
time and again they're attached to this
this is the core stage 212 feet tall the
largest single stage we've ever
constructed it's been through the green
run test a lot of preparation for this
flight today and it is propelled by
these four rs-25 engines now these are
liquid-fueled rocket engines so you have
a fuel and an oxidizer and one of the
great things about liquid fuel is you
can throttle them in real time you could
kind of like the gas in your car you can
go faster a little bit slower so these
throttle up to a hundred and four
percent of their rated thrust at the
time of liftoff we throttle them down as
we go through Max use the maximum amount
of pressure on SLS in the way uphill and
then throttle them back up until they've
consumed all of their propellants and
they're consuming that propellant at
more than 50 500 gallons a second that
is just an astronomical amount of fuel
that's running through these engines to
produce that thrust each of these up to
half a million pounds each during their
operation
and of all the different components
we've got this engine block section down
here you have all of the Associated
Plumbing everything to feed those
propellants down to these engines you
also have these two attachment points
here and that's where we actually tank
the SLS rocket so a lot of focus on
those in the previous attempts they've
cooperated spectacularly so far today
and we've been able to fully tank this
core stage and reminder you have a fuel
about half a million gallons right here
of liquid hydrogen and then an oxidizer
you need those two together and then an
ignition Source that's what gives you
your reaction your thrust your basically
controlled explosion that then comes out
of those rocket engines so fully tanked
these are cryogenic fuels hundreds of
degrees below zero so we've got a
spray-on insulation across the entire
vehicle as it's sitting out there in the
Florida Air it's a little bit warm
tonight but we need to keep those
hundreds of degrees below zero it takes
a lot of energy to do that so the less
you have to use used to keep them cold
the better which is why we have that
insulation so we're going to be seeing
SLS take flight for the first time
tonight as we clear all of those final
issues again this is going to be one
heck of a show when this thing launches
into the night sky so with that send it
back over to you Megan
NASA's kind of
can enter for a live launch
Artemis one I'm NASA's Megan Cruz and
this is NASA astronaut Kayla Barron it's
been great having you these past two
hours it's been so awesome to be here
for this historic launch tonight so
right now we are awaiting a new t0 the
launch team had to work through some
issues and they're doing a great job at
working through those issues so now
we're just waiting to see a new t0 since
we had been aiming for the top of the
launch window which opened our wood does
open at 104 a.m eastern time now today
is a big deal Apollo 17 in 1972 was the
last time humans stepped foot on the
Moon that uh the rocket you see right
there behind us illuminated in the
darkness there is the first step back
towards getting us to the moon now
Artemis one is the first integrated
flight test of NASA's deep space
exploration systems that's the ground
systems here at Kennedy Space Center the
space launch system or SLS Rockets and
the Orion spacecraft we will send and
send an uncrewed Orion spacecraft
farther beyond the moon than any of of
the Apollo missions before it for
Artemis 2 Orion will have astronauts on
board as it orbits the moon then future
Artemis missions will land the first
woman and first person of color on the
surface of the Moon
so Kayla why do we want to go back to
the Moon
the moon's a super interesting place to
study it can tell us a lot about the
Earth its own formation but also more
about our solar system and we also want
to return this time in an international
partnership for a permanent presence on
the lunar surface that'll teach us
everything we need to know to travel on
to Mars and what about for you I mean
you have the possibility of maybe being
selected for those future missions
because they the Artemis program can
choose from any of you guys any of the
NASA astronauts
it's a crazy time to be a NASA astronaut
and even imagine that that could be real
I think we're all just honored to be a
part of the team that's doing this we're
just a small representation of all of
the amazing human beings around the
world that it takes to do something as
audacious as returning to the Moon
learning what we need to go on to Mars
so we're just all excited to support the
program in any way we can but of course
a ride to the Moon would be incredible
so I think we're all just dreaming about
those Moonwalks now since Artemis one is
setting the stage for those future crude
missions is there anything in particular
about this 26-day mission that you will
be watching is it re-entry
yeah you know we've mentioned that a few
times throughout the broadcast tonight
the re-entry is a really important part
of the flight of course and the heat
shield we're interested in seeing how it
performs in real life we tested it on
the ground but Orion's going to be
coming in faster and hotter than any
human rated spacecraft in history and so
we really want to see how the heat
shield performs and make sure all the
systems can keep the crew safe for that
Dynamic event yeah we'll all be watching
for that too it's not just about the
launch the 26 day Mission as we said so
we'll be keeping a watch over the entire
Mission our Workforce Now is very
different from what it was during the
Apollo era when Apollo 11 launched there
was only one female engineer in the
firing room today's launch of Artemis
one is led by NASA's first ever female
launch director take a look at how she
and other women across NASA are
shattering glass ceilings
when I was a little girl I wanted to be
an astronaut a scientist a doctor a
fighter pilot when I was a little girl I
wanted to grow up to be strong and
independent when we were asked to draw a
picture of what we wanted to be when we
grew up I drew an astronaut standing on
the surface of the Moon all I thought
about was when I was going to get to
NASA
[Music]
honor to be NASA's first female watch
director to be the launch director for
Artemis
NASA has so many wonderful women
Pioneers so many Heroes to me some of
the most amazing women in my eyes are
people like Catherine Johnson and the
other women that you've seen in Hidden
figures
[Music]
sometimes it's difficult to believe that
I'm on this side now wearing this Blue
flight suit with all of the other
astronauts representing this iconic
image that had so inspired and excited
me my entire life
being of South Asian Heritage kalpana
chawa was just such a big thing for me
growing up I've always looked up to
Sally Ride and Mae Jemison who really
laid the foundation to allow people like
me to be in the position that I am now
all of these women were pushing those
boundaries and breaking those black
ceilings now of course there are some
fantastic women in leadership positions
that inspire me every day
so much has changed since the Apollo
program during the Apollo 11 launch we
had one woman one out of 400 engineers
in the room and I look at our team today
it's much more reflection of the world
that we live in
a big piece of why it's so important to
have women and diverse backgrounds
because it allows us to bring everybody
along with us on this journey it doesn't
really matter what you look like if
you've got the brains and you have the
knowledge we need you at the table
we are at such an exciting time in human
space flight right now and Artemis is
such a huge part of that we haven't been
to the Moon in many many years we have a
lot of younger generation folks that
have never seen that happen we will
understand so much more about the moon
about the Earth about our solar system
we're going to stay and to me that's an
amazing idea the moon is going to be the
blueprint for how we go to Mars and out
into the solar system and maybe Beyond
it is incredibly exciting to be part of
this Artemis team it still feels pretty
surreal to think that I might one day
walk on the moon to see a woman in a
person of color on the surface of the
Moon to be able to say that space is for
everyone and that we go to space to make
life better here on Earth for everyone I
know that tears will be in my eyes
[Music]
my message to women and girls out there
is to find your passion whatever that is
don't let anyone tell you what you can
do or can't do only you can realize your
dreams Faith it's for everyone and if me
being in this role helps to send that
message I think that's a great thing I
just actually love that I don't feel
like a woman at Nasa I just feel like a
person at Nasa the women of NASA are
Ottomans and we make a difference every
day
I am NASA's spacewalk office Hardware
manager I'm the program scientist for
space biology I'm the director of NASA's
Johnson Space Center I am Artemis I am
Artemus
I am Artemis
I just love the way that that video ends
with you and all these other women
saying I am Artemis what do you think
why is it so powerful to just hear those
three words I am Artemis why does that
resonate so much
I think it just represents how far we've
come since the Apollo area era and how
we take advantage of the incredible
diversity our country has to offer
having seats at the table for everyone
you know spaces for everyone you heard
that a few times in the video and I
think we're proving that out every
single day in our work not just at Nasa
but with our International Partners I
think it's so important to our ability
to succeed on these really complex
missions yeah I thought that was a very
powerful video and and I'm glad that
people got that message young girls in
particular
another person who you saw in that video
is uh Pam melroy she's a former
astronaut and NASA's Deputy
Administrator so why don't we head over
to Jasmine Hopkins because Pam is there
with her now thank you so much Megan yes
I am honored now to be joined by Pam
Milroy NASA Deputy Administrator this is
just a fantastic night we just saw that
powerful video with you among so many of
the Great women here at Nasa what is so
important about us now being ready to
send you know the first woman the first
person of color to the Moon Yeah I loved
watching that video just inspires me so
many of those women are my friends but
also they're just such fantastic
engineers and scientists and just so
many roles at the agency I've always
thought one of the strongest teams that
you could ever find is a family and
families have men and women and so our
teams are stronger I think when we have
that balance and that diversity so that
was exciting but for me I was a part of
the Apollo generation and I was very
inspired by you know Neil Armstrong and
Buzz Aldrin and Mike Collins on Apollo
11 and all the Apollo Astronauts
I just cannot even imagine the
inspiration though for a little girl I
mean it never
occurred to me that there I mean I
wanted to be an astronaut but of course
there were no women astronauts then I
think what's going to happen now with
the Artemis generation is that that
first woman and the first person of
color is just going to have a huge
impact on the Next Generation right we
are just watching with baited breath and
I know that it's going to mean so much
to little kids to look up to them and
and we understand too this is a huge I
mean when we launch Artemis it's going
to be a global accomplishment we have
the Artemis Accords which are helping us
make sure we explore peacefully can you
tell us more about those yeah it's
really important actually especially
because you know unlike in Apollo where
it was actually just a few countries
that had the capability to go to space
now those capabilities are proliferating
throughout the world and so what we do
with the rocket is really important and
how we go is is just as important and
how we go is as teams and with our
partners and with a sense of the
response ability that we have as we go
out into the solar system to do it
peacefully for scientific purposes and
responsibly right Pam you have a great
sense of teamwork and this is definitely
not our first time you know there's a
lot of things that go into testing out a
first-time vehicle there's actually
Dynamic activity going on right now so
how does this first flight test of SLS
compare to other first times you know
with shuttle or with Saturn V before
that well I can I can do even better as
a test pilot right so there's a history
there
um in fact the you know the amazing
thing about this is it so first flight
of a first aircraft you actually taxi it
out to the end of the runway and then
run down the runway and come back and
check all the data then you might take
off once and go around the pattern and
come back and land this is a little bit
like taking off and going to fly a full
mission on your very first flight of an
aircraft and so everything has to be
right so this Compares very you know
it's very similar to the experiences
that all new rocket developments have
where you know it's not just about
learning the hardware that's a big piece
of it but it's also about gelling that
team together and your procedures and
how you're going to deal with issues
that come up because they will come up
they always come up exactly and you have
that experience as a test pilot but also
as a former astronaut in that video we
saw you getting your induction into the
Astronaut Hall of Fame which is pretty
cool so what is your perspective or what
advice do you have for the Artemis
astronauts those ones that are are going
to maybe set foot on the moon oh well
they don't need my advice I'd love to
Elbow them out of the way
they are fantastic I mean we are I'm so
proud of all of our astronauts I was
just talking to Jessica Watkins who just
came back on crew for this generation is
prepared ready and excited and I think
they're really excited that we're
putting science front and center in the
Artemis program too we're going to learn
so much about the cell solar system from
the Moon and even about the Earth and so
that I think the astronauts are really
excited about doing that Hands-On
science and they're they're they are
ready to go right I know they're ready
to go and maybe you are as well but
Artemis one is just the beginning then
we have Artemis two and on we're
learning so much what do you think about
this this forward movement that we're
making right now well it's really
important this is uh the Artemis
campaign is actually part of a
multi-decade effort that we're doing
right now which is really with the goal
of creating a blueprint for how we're
going to explore with humans and do
science throughout the solar system so
we're going to learn through the Artemis
campaign on the moon and then we're
going to go demonstrate it on Mars and
then the next destination who knows
where right I mean we're going so much
further than we ever have before
pamelroy thank you so much for joining
us thank you go Artemis of course go
Artemis Megan back to you
thank you both for That interview now
teams over at NASA's Johnson Space
Center also monitoring today's launched
attempt so why don't we go back over
there with Leah to tell us what's going
on over there
thanks Megan and you're right teams here
in Mission Control Houston continue to
monitor today's events again they will
really kick into action once we have
liftoff and they'll remain on Console
all the way through Splashdown but
quickly I have to show you something a
little show and tell makes me feel like
the coolest kid in school I've got a
moon rock here I hope you can get a good
shot of it it is from Apollo 15 1971 and
when it was brought back to Earth it was
part of a larger Rock in total it was 21
pounds this is of course a smaller
section of that but we're looking
forward to the Artemis program and being
able to go back to the moon so that we
can continue to gather these kinds of
samples but this time at the lunar South
Pole we've never been there and we've
never brought samples back from that
area so we're really excited to see what
might differ in those samples and the
ones that we have here now of course
we've got a whole laboratory of
scientists that are able to study all of
those samples we just opened some up for
the first time earlier this year so that
we're able to test with new technology
everything that we can learn about these
samples that we brought back now 50
years ago so hopefully within the next
few years we're bringing some new ones
back uh to to use that same experimental
process on and tell us a little bit more
about the moon but just had to show this
off Apollo 15 Moon Rock we're looking
forward to having some Artist Artemis
ones here at Johnson Space Center with
that I will send it back to you at KSC
you are a cool kid before you even had
the moon rock so but now you're even a
cooler kid
now the name Artemis was chosen because
in Greek mythology she's the twin sister
of Apollo NASA's Leo Martin is over at
the nearby Kennedy Space Center Visitor
complex where thousands have gathered to
watch today's launch attempt
Hi Megan I'm actually joined here
tonight by a very special group of
guests uh here from stennis visiting
Kennedy Space Center why don't you tell
me Ryan what it is that ties you to
tonight's launch
so we were lucky and privileged enough
to be able to test the core stage of the
SLS rocket that's going to launch today
we've got a green run which is a full
duration Hot Fire
it's a very historic time for us at
stennis it was so exciting to be a part
of it was seven years of hard work by a
lot of really great people and Jack oh
sorry I'm just so excited to be here to
see it and Jack you were actually
telling me that you know firsthand you
know how much work has gone into
tonight's launch what does it feel like
to be here tonight seeing the rocket
fully integrated on the pad ready to go
man I'm just incredibly grateful to be a
part of this history and just really
excited to see this thing launch
and uh Barry you were uh telling me that
you know also firsthand you know the
adversity that these teams have overcome
to be here tonight do you have a word of
encouragement anything that you'd like
to say to the teams all across the
United States right now both in Kennedy
and at JSC who are just sitting in these
seats ready to get the rocket launched
tonight sure persevere I mean it's hard
work but it's so well worth it
um we spent many hours doing the testing
and trying to get ready for this moment
and I think we've forwarded that
information to those guys and we also
give them the encouragement to continue
on so we know they can do it thanks so
much Barry and I think it would be great
if just let the Catherine we can give
them a great big go Artemis one two
three
back to you Megan
that was amazing uh and that's just uh
uh you know people who were actually
able to come here to Florida there's
many uh people who are joining us from
around the world who couldn't obviously
make the trip out here uh so let's take
a look at some of those watch parties
there here's Space Center Houston it's
the visitor center over uh for Johnson
Space Center in Houston and you can see
a lot of people there after hours
because you know that visitor center is
closed right now people are waving I
love it wow look at that whatever that
is it's amazing I don't think I've ever
noticed that when I'm at Space Center
Houston maybe it's new I know but yeah
just look at that crowd it's really fun
to see again all all these people who
are captivated young and old by today's
launch attempt and the beginning of the
Artemis program I know that they're uh
probably looking at the clock and and
wondering when we might see the launch
today so lovely to see all those people
and there's the Space and Rocket Center
uh where we have a ton of people waiting
leaders cheering us on tonight for this
incredible launch this evening I love
that they totally look like cheerleaders
and I they're embracing it I love it uh
and yeah this is the U.S Basin Rocket
Center this is the visitor center over
in Huntsville Alabama as I've said
before uh this uh that uh
um Marshall space flight center there is
a super instrumental uh in uh What uh
what the Artemis program is doing that
they uh contributed a lot to the mission
so it's nice to see everyone there and
then here is Airbus in Bremen Germany so
Airbus is the main contractor for the
European space agency and together the
company and Issa they provided the
European service module which is uh an
important part of the Orion spacecraft
so we have quite a bit of people there a
more reasonable time over there in
Germany it is 7 00 a.m so I'm gonna say
Guten Morgen to them did I say it right
Guten Morgen to them over there uh in
Brevin Germany again the Airbus company
all right so let's get another check on
the launch team with our Daryl nail
who's inside there and has an update for
us
yeah that's right Megan so we are
clearly in a delay now the NASA test
director who's basically flying the ship
for the launch countdown tonight has
said that uh we are extending the hold
that we were currently in at T minus 10
minutes and Counting and so that puts us
off the 104 a.m Eastern Time launch
we're now slipping indefinitely into the
hold NASA test director Carlos mange
saying that we are currently
estimating how much work needs to be
done
before resuming uh the polling that
supposed to take place 15 minutes before
launch it then goes to terminal count at
T minus 10 minutes and we've got an
update on the tanking of the upper stage
liquid hydrogen tank currently 95
percent filled we're in topping on that
tank it is the last of four tanks in the
space launch system that needed to be
completely fueled up before we launch of
course cryogenic tanking a complex
operation that has seen some delays
tonight we had a roughly hour delay
after replenish valve on the core stage
liquid hydrogen side required Hands-On
work by a red crew team that went out to
the launch pad and tightened down some
bolts on the valve and got it fixed
before leaving the launch pad and then
launch Team verifying that that work was
complete now currently we're awaiting
some work with the range the 45th space
Wing which oversees the range here makes
sure that the airspace and uh and the
ocean out over the flight path is clear
and also has the responsibility to
destruct the rocket should it go off
track and they are been working on some
issues with their equipment and sending
a flight termination signal to the
rocket that that uh there is testing
that must happen with the flight
termination system that was delayed by a
bad ethernet switch switch has been
changed out and now the range is looking
to start testing their connectivity to
the rocket in order to preserve that
safety function that they are
responsible for
so again we are slipping now
indefinitely into the launch window
um we're awaiting uh the launch Team to
evaluate just how much time is required
to complete the work to get this rocket
ready to launch and of course when we
have a new t0 for you we'll report that
out right away Megan back to you
Daryl thank you so much as NASA prepares
to explore the moon here's a look at the
spacesuits and tools that will help us
to do that
[Music]
watching Apollo footage of astronauts
doing geology on the surface of the Moon
is a really great way to think about
preparing for Artemis for putting people
on the lunar surface once again
we learn a lot in how they did science
operations on the Moon and what it's
like to work on the moon you see them
doing geology you see them taking Rock
samples putting in a drive tube to take
a core sample you see them bouncing
along the surface of the Moon on the
lunar rover that they used in Apollo 15
through 17. so it's a great way to help
Drive technology development for the
next generation of spacesuits and
geology sampling tools there's these
facilities that help us train like we
are on the lunar surface you know these
16g offload systems or putting people in
the Aquatic environment are great ways
to train the mobility part right like
what can you do and how different does
it feel to be in 16g and do these tasks
we've been training astronauts in
geology and geoscience for decades now
the Apollo Astronauts had literally
hundreds of hours of training in geology
before they flew to the moon it's often
said that the Apollo Astronauts had the
equivalent of a master's degree in
geology by the time they flew to
in the intervening decades since Apollo
we've been training astronauts who fly
to the International Space Station
because when they're on the ISS they
spend time observing the Earth looking
out the window taking pictures of what
they see on the Earth's surface now that
we're looking at putting astronauts on
the surface of the Moon we also take
them into the field we take them to
field sites here on Earth that resemble
field sites that we expect them to see
on the moon that's the reason why we
take them out into places that are
unique like volcanic Landscapes or
places that are analogous to the lunar
surface to train them on the scale and
Fidelity of science that you just can't
recreate in these facilities and so by
combining this classroom and field
training we're able to prep them for
fundamentals of geology the major
driving lunar science questions that we
have that we hope to address with the
Artemis program and teaching them how to
do field work in relevant analog
environments for just science aspects of
developing new spacesuits can it get you
to where you need to go and then once
you get there can you do the cool
science that you need to do and so
that's can you move effectively and
efficiently in the suit to be able to
collect the samples or use the tools or
the instruments for the visibility it's
like can you make the necessary
observations that you need to or does
the suit have the lights on it that it
needs to to illuminate the surface and
make the observations you need to
the lunar South Pole holds tremendous
resources that are going to allow us to
continue to explore this is this is a
place that we've never been before
there's so much to be learned from
getting boots on the ground and
exploring a unique place that challenges
us so that humans and also helps us
develop technologies that make our
everyday life that much better we think
there might be volatiles present at the
South Pole by using these volatiles
we'll be able to do things like create
drinking water create rocket fueled
launch astronauts back to Earth and so
by harnessing the power of the land
we'll be able to help astronauts
establish that long-term sustainable
presence
[Music]
it's human nature to explore pushing our
boundaries and exploring our universes I
think just one of those things that's
just stuck in our human nature and that
we need to do it in order to understand
the world around us including our Earth
and our solar system
[Music]
we just heard there how curiosity is
just a part of us so with that in mind
why don't we do some social questions
because some people are very curious to
hear what you have to say about their
questions so why don't we pull up the
first question here
what are your thoughts on the
responsibilities that come with going to
space obviously a question for you I am
not going to space
yeah the opportunity to travel to space
is it comes with a lot of responsibility
I think for all of us it's a huge honor
to be a part of these teams and the work
we're doing is so critical in supporting
scientific discovery on the ground so on
the International Space Station we're a
National Laboratory our crew executed
over 350 different scientific
experiments during our six-month Mission
and so when you think about that it's
years of work to get one of these
payloads or an experiment on the space
station and sometimes that someone's
life's work you're holding in your hands
and executing and so being prepared for
those moments is really important and
understanding how to bring the team from
the ground into solving complex problems
we take that really really seriously and
of course we want to share what that
experience is like only a few people
have been able to go to space and as we
commercialize space as low earth orbit
becomes more accessible that'll change
but still it's only available to some of
us so we really want to share what
that's like and the perspective we gain
from our 10 I'm up there it's really
great to see and hear that you guys
acknowledge that right like that this
experiment that you're holding that
you're working on for six months
somebody has been working on literally
for years I mean I've talked to some
scientists and they're saying oh this
has been my life's work 20 years of my
life's work so so yeah that was a really
good question I like that question a lot
okay we have another one from social
media here Astro Kayla have you
considered what you might say if you had
the opportunity to be the first female
to set foot on the moon's surface
um no
um if I was in that role it's something
I would take really seriously I think
the iconic words of Neil Armstrong you
know one small step for man one giant
leap for mankind are something that we
all know whether you witness that moment
or not or it happened before you were
born for like for me I think we all have
that embedded in our psyche that's
important word so I think it's something
I would have to think a lot about ahead
of that mission yeah that would be in
the history of books that'll be
something you're remembered for oh my
gosh I'd be so anxious delivering it
even after I've thought of what I want
to say like to actually open my mouth
and say it from the surface of the Moon
wow yeah that we'll have to think about
that for sure
okay let's see another question here oh
why is the spacesuit orange in color
that's an awesome question that I wish I
knew the answer to Megan and I were
actually talking about that earlier when
we had Snoopy up here it's a
continuation of the same suit that we
used during the shuttle era and I was
kind of hypothesizing that maybe it's to
help forces if for some reason when we
landed in the water we had to get out of
the capsule for some reason it would be
easy to see us
um but that I'm gonna have to take a
phone a friend on that one I think to
know the real answer I'm sure somebody
will be commenting on social media right
now with the what the real history right
now I'm trying to think about it too I'm
thinking does it have anything to do
with SLS being orange because yeah
that was our first one that we got
stuffed on
do we have another question
all right if you could name one of the
moon's craters what would you name it oh
man what would you name it Megan I don't
know that's a big decision I thought you
might say the name of your zero g grass
oh wow yeah maybe I don't know that's a
like pretty big responsibility I think
to name these geological features and a
lot of the craters on the moon already
have names so I'm sure there's some that
maybe they haven't named they're too
small or we haven't explored them yet
but a lot of them already do have names
like we're going to be exploring the
edge of Shackleton crater as part of
Artemis Mission so a lot of them are
already named and mapped yeah thanks for
throwing it back on me I was like I
don't know do you think like our parents
or or husband or fiancee are now upset
that we didn't say them I don't know I
mean I don't think so I think they
understand
all right these are big decisions this
is all right last question here for this
segment at least what will Orion do when
it gets to the Moon
um so for this Mission Artemis one it's
actually going to orbit the Moon and
then go into a distant retrograde orbit
and so it'll get really close as close
as 62 miles and then go way past the
moon
um and way deeper into space than we've
ever been before so yeah the Orion
vehicle will be checking out all of its
systems we're going to be analyzing that
data from the ground and then we're
going to see that it can survive
re-entry and a successful Splashdown off
the coast of San Diego yeah yeah that
was a good question too okay well again
just keep those questions coming you
know we do we are entering into this
launch window and we do have time so
we'd love to hear from you and we'd love
to try at least to answer most of your
questions so you've been hearing
throughout the broadcast all the
different science that returning to the
moon will enable us to do so there's
actually something called the prime one
mining it's experiment and that's going
to robotically look for ice and other
resources below the lunar surface
NASA's first polar resources ice mining
experiment also known as prime one will
robotically look for ice and other
resources below the lunar surface
thanks to data from spacecraft orbiting
the moon scientists believe that the
polar regions contain Water Ice in the
form of ice just below the surface
with the right technologies that ice is
a game-changing resource that can be
mined and used to produce propellant and
breathable oxygen for future explorers
under NASA's commercial lunar payload
Services initiative the agency selected
intuitive machines to fly and land prime
one on the moon's South Pole
prime one will land near the Shackleton
crater to drill into the lunar soil in
an area that could contain Water Ice
prime one is made up of two instruments
Trident the regolith and Ice drill for
exploring new terrain and M solo the
mass spectrometer observing lunar
operations
Trident will drill up to three feet into
the lunar surface extract lunar soil and
bring it up to the surface
Trident drills to its maximum depth in
multiple phases stopping at different
increments
as it reaches each desired depth it will
pause and retract the drill string to
deposit lunar soil on the surface for
analysis
this is where M solo comes in
M solo is a commercial off-the-shelf
Mass spectrometer modified for space
flight it will evaluate the chemical
elements and compounds released from the
lunar soil for water and other chemical
compounds
Trident will then proceed to the next
specified depth and repeat the process
until samples at all desired depths have
been analyzed for water
if no ice is found where prime one lands
NASA will still collect valuable
information about drilling into the
lunar soil for a future Mission NASA's
Viper the volatiles investigating polar
exploration Rover will use prime 1
technology on a mobile robot that will
navigate the moon's South Pole searching
for additional resources
prime one data will help NASA assess
lunar resources to inform future Artemis
missions and a robust human presence on
the moon
so we are away we are still awaiting a
new t0 for today's launch attempt but
for more on what to expect when we
launch uh for this first day let's go to
NASA's Dan Hewitt he's inside our Apollo
Saturn 5 Center at the KSC visitor
complex hey thanks Megan everybody
Welcome Back To The Moon board there's a
lot of people here in the complex I just
heard a woohoo people are getting in and
out because we have a great view of
launch when it's going to happen and
it's going to happen today but that
launch is just the first step in the
Artemis One mission so let's look at
what's ahead for this historic First
Flight as we just said launch is Step
number one those four rs-25 engines
throttle up followed shortly after by
the two solid rocket boosters igniting
sending SLS and Orion Skyward now on our
way uphill we'll have a number of Jedis
events you'll be able to see things
coming off of the SLS rocket one of the
most visual ones will be these two solid
rocket boosters now they'll expend their
propel a little over two minutes into
the flight they will separate we'll see
them flare off onto either side and then
the core stage continues to fire we're
also going to see the launch abort
system come off the top once you get
high enough in the atmosphere it's no
longer required you could actually do
aborts using engines on Orion and its
service module I will also note that on
the launch abort system it's got those
three solid rocket Motors the jettison
motor is active the abort and the
attitude ones are not for this flight we
don't have people so we're not flying a
fully active abort system we also have
three fairings that are there to protect
Orion the service module and the crew
module as we're flying up through the
really dense parts of the Earth's
atmosphere next up we'll hit core stage
separation so we've got four main
engines we'll hear Mikko main engine cut
off those engines will shut down the
core stage will separate drop away it's
eventually going to splash down in the
ocean and that hands over the propulsion
duties to this our upper stage the
interim cryogenic propulsion stage or
icps
its first job is to execute what's known
as a perigee raised maneuver so the
perigee is the lowest part of your orbit
you have a perigee that's your low part
an apogee that's your highest point
we're going to raise up the perigee and
that's going to actually put us in a
nice circular path around the planet and
while we're there that gives us time to
check out Orion we're flying it in space
for the second time the first time in
this fully integrated stack with SLS
we'll be able to look at all of Orion's
systems make sure those solar arrays are
capturing the sun's energy and turning
it into electrical power for Orion
systems make sure the communications are
working all of our guidance navigation
within control that is your time to make
sure you have a healthy spacecraft
before you do something that is going to
send it to the moon and that's next up
on our list that's the trans lunar
injection for today's launch profile
that's going to be a firing of about 18
minutes of that single engine on the
upper stage now that engine optimized
for about vacuum it's producing about 24
000 pounds of thrust so it's a pretty
big engine and it's doing that because
we need enough energy
to be able to send our payload Orion
Beyond low earth orbit and send it on a
path to head out to the Moon
now after that burn is complete icps
separates it's going to do what's called
a disposal burn so it's going to send
itself on a path from Earth around the
moon and slingshot out into what's known
as a heliocentric orbit so it's going to
completely leave the Earth Moon system
and go into orbit around our sun
but after it separates propulsion duties
get handed over to this the European
service module and it's got a couple of
different engines that it's going to be
using and we're going to be testing
those out just on day one we're going to
do what's called the outbound trajectory
correction burn one and we'll do a
couple of these trajectory corrections
as we're flying out to the moon but that
first one is that first critical test of
this large engine the orbital
maneuvering system engine that's the one
that has the most thrust generating
about six thousand pounds of force in a
vacuum and that's what's going to be
doing a lot of our Maneuvers are giving
us that pushing power as we do these
Maneuvers around the Moon to enter into
what's known as distant retrograde orbit
or Dro and that's this dotted line that
you see around here now we call it
distant basically because of the
distance we're away from the Moon we're
about 40 000 miles a little bit less off
the lunar surface and then we call it
retrograde because the moon orbiting
planet Earth in this direction going in
a counterclock wise fashion we're going
to be entering into a clockwise orbit
around the Moon opposite retrograde now
to do that we're going to get in close
we're going to dip in off the lunar
surface we're going to be about 80 miles
80 statute miles off the lunar surface
as we do this outbound powered flyby
again the major thrust coming from that
orbital maneuvering system engine after
we do that we'll do a final maneuver to
actually go into that distant retrograde
orbit that Dro now why Dro why are we
not just going around the moon and
coming back on like a free return
trajectory which he did on some of the
Apollo missions well in Dro it's a very
stable orbit it doesn't require a lot of
fuel to maintain that area around the
moon so it gives you a lot of time to
really test the spacecraft if you
followed with any launch of a new
spacecraft you know there's only so much
testing you can do on the ground once
you actually put all of that Hardware in
space in the environment that it's going
to be be operating hundreds of thousands
of vials away from Earth you're going to
learn things you didn't even realize
about everything from Communications the
life support systems the thermal control
everything on a spacecraft needs to get
put through its Paces in this
environment before we put people on
board and that's why we're heading out
to Dro
eventually though it's going to be time
to come home and we will do a Dro
departure maneuver this again firing up
that orbital maneuvering system engine
and others on the service module and
this is what's going to commit us from
leaving the moon and heading on back
towards Earth we'll dip in Once More
close off the lunar surface and
slingshot and use the lunar gravity to
do this return powered flyby and then
similar to the way out we can make
correction Burns as we kind of fine tune
our path back towards the Earth and then
it's time for re-entry a couple of
things happen before that one of the
really critical ones spacecraft
separation we're going to detach the
European service module shortly before
re-entry its job largely done that burns
up in the Earth's atmosphere and reveals
on the crew module the heat shield I
circled it earlier this is goal number
one of the Artemis Mission Artemis One
mission is testing this heat shield at
lunar return velocities because we when
we make that trip around the moon and we
come back we are going in speeds of
excess of 20 000 miles an hour so when
we slam into the Earth's atmosphere it's
going to heat that thing up to more
excuse me more than 5 000 degrees
Fahrenheit uh for the Artemis one
profile we're going to do what's known
as the skip re-entry so basically you
can come into shallow and Skip off the
atmosphere to to narrow and you're going
to do what's known as a ballistic entry
which really Heats things up we're going
to do kind of a mix where we're going to
skip once off the atmosphere and that
we're still going to get the heat but
that helps to reduce some of the G loads
on the crew once you're through that you
get to parachute deploy there's 11
parachutes in total that are going to
slow Orion down before it splashes down
we're going to be going from 20 000
miles an hour to about 300 miles an hour
before those parachutes deploy and then
they do a final job of getting it in the
water in the South Pacific we've got
these big Orange balloons that's an
uprighting system so
even if Orion landed in the water upside
down those can those can inflate and
they put us back upright into what's
known as stable one that's where you
want your spacecraft to be nice and
upright in the water especially if
you're an astronaut and they're floating
now we also have a large U.S Navy ship
with a big Bay that's going to basically
come up and swallow Orion into its deck
and you've got a couple of other assets
in the area to help recover Hardware the
forward bait cover parachutes things
like that but that's scheduled to happen
26 days after a launch today so that's
26 days from liftoff here in Florida
around the Moon to a splash down in the
Pacific and that will be the first
mission in the Artemis program the
farthest we've ever sent a human rated
spacecraft in history and just the first
step before we put people on board so
that's a look at everything still to
come we're counting down to that launch
I'll send it back over to Megan and the
team at the host desk guys okay very
comprehensive look at that thank you so
much Dan if you're just joining us
welcome to Kennedy Space Center and our
live coverage of Artemis one an uncrewed
flight tests that will return us to the
Moon in nearly 50 years but you know
some might ask why the moon well here's
why
we are going
the history of this agency is marked
with broken barriers once viewed as
impossible
with science fiction turned reality
with innovations that have spun
Industries all their own
and with demonstrations of Peace for all
humankind
soar in the skies of our home planet
we maintain a human presence just
outside of gravity and we touch points
all across the solar system and beyond
we're going back to the moon and this is
why
the Moon is a treasure Trove of science
it holds opportunities for us to make
discoveries about our home planet about
our sun and about our solar system the
wealth of knowledge to be gleaned from
the moon will inspire a new generation
of thought and action without fail every
major program and mission NASA has
invested in has led to Technologies and
capabilities that have shaped our
culture the breakthroughs of the Artemis
era will Define Our Generation and the
generations to follow the tens of
thousands of jobs associated with
propelling us to the Moon today by just
the beginning of a lunar economy that
will see hundreds of thousands of new
jobs developed around the world this is
not an ambition of one entity or one
country the exploration of the moon is a
shared effort woven together by a desire
for the greater good why the moon
because the missions of Tomorrow Will Be
sparked by the accomplishments of the
Artemis generation today because the
ambition to go has already begun and
because Mars is calling we need to learn
what it takes to establish a community
upon another Cosmic Shore so let's Camp
close before pushing out
and so we go to the moon now not as a
series of isolated missions
but to build a community on and around
the Moon capable of proving how to live
on other worlds
[Music]
we'll use the lessons for more than 50
years of peaceful exploration to send a
new generation to the lunar surface to
stay we will anchor our efforts on the
lunar South Pole to establish the
artemis-based camp positioning us for
long-term science and exploration of the
lunar service we will prove what it
takes to assemble a complex ship in deep
space we will perfect
and returning from a distance service we
will learn how humans can survive and
thrive in the partial gravity
environment with improved spacesuit
designs mobile habitats and with
reconnaissance robots pre-positioning
and relocating supplies we will learn
how to utilize the resources we find on
this overalls starting with finding
water ice and purifying it to drinkable
water and in finding that into hydrogen
concealed and oxygen degree we will
establish fission power plants on the
surface of the Moon capable of
supporting a growing community of
efforts and we will expand the logistics
supply chain to enable commercial and
international Partners to resupply and
refuel deep space outposts
none of this is simple or easy but
nothing in our history ever has been
you got a bunch of guys about to turn
blue we're breathing again thanks a lot
this kind of continuous lunar presence
is a natural extension of all that we've
learned in low earth orbit
and what we will accomplish there will
ensure the Monumental missions to Mars
are within reach
as we ready the launch of the first
Artemis mission
and as commercial companies ready their
lunar Landers for the first private
payload deliveries we have already begun
to take the next step
[Music]
throughout this launch broadcast our
NASA's Leah Martin has been introducing
us to people over at the Kennedy Space
Center Visitor complex who have come out
for uh hopefully the maiden voyage of
Artemis one people from near and far
young and old just really excited to
hopefully see this historic flight so
now she's joined by somebody else who
has a really interesting story Leah tell
us about it Megan I think one of the
most exciting things about being here
tonight is being with people who are
like-minded who have such a strong tie
to the history of our nation's space
program and their love of space flight
and I actually struck up an amazing
conversation with Scott here and you
were telling me about the special tie
that you have to tonight's launch as
well oh yeah I grew up literally grew up
with NASA my father went to work with
the NACA before NASA went to work for Dr
Von Braun followed him over to Marshall
space flight center and became you know
when it became NASA a he worked on the
Jupiter C Redstone Saturn one Saturn V
and then because of that he brought me
here to see Apollo 11 launch
so that was my first launch I was five
years old it loved it still remember the
sound that's about all but and then
years later through my flying career
I was able to bring my sons back with my
friends that flew the shuttle and they
saw five launches and
four Landings but basically I wanted to
be here I was here for the first moon
launch
the last Moon launched back when Uncle
Gene cernan our family friend went to
Apollo 17. so I wanted to be here for
this because it's it's kind of in our
family in our blood
and hopefully I'll be around for the
next one when we go and land again so
that's
yeah yeah
I knew most of the German scientists the
kids sit in our lap Dr Ernst Erlanger
and my father flew at Von Braun because
he was a general aviation pilot as well
so they get off work and fly and it was
they were in Life Magazine together
National Geographic so it was fun I
literally got to
knew Al Shepherd all the Mercury Gemini
Apollo guys
and it was an honor I I would have loved
to been an astronaut but I went a
different route
and but I can still come here and see
him we can and we're so so grateful so
thrilled to see you here tonight and so
excited that you will be able to
actually compare the last launch in the
sound of the last one with the one
tonight it's absolutely gonna rock this
guy to be even louder
well thanks so much for joining us
tonight it's been an honor to meet you
and Megan we're going back to you
So yeah thank you so much for sharing
that that was such a fun story here we
are now at Space Center Houston this is
a live look inside of the visitor center
there uh lots of people uh hoping to see
the launch today I love this guy in the
front with his NASA shirt representing
uh and again just seeing children and
young and old just all these people who
uh feel captivated and are excited about
our next giant Leaf into deep space so
glad to have them here oh my gosh I love
this yeah the team in Marshall in
Huntsville there is always ready for
their shot their flag they're super
pumped that's the home to the SLS
program office so they have a dog in the
fight tonight
Artemis launch for the first time is
that an inflatable
astronaut in the center Center do you
see that I think somebody is dressed up
yeah we're ready to go I love this yeah
I'm so glad that they're there again
these visitor centers are closed to the
public but uh you know the people there
decided to hold a watch party oh look
how excited Germany are you ready for us
this time
anticipated the delay they look pumped
and ready to go so these are employees
of Airbus Airbus is the main contractor
for the European space agency and
together they provided the European
service module for the Orion spacecraft
so really we should be applauding them
they shouldn't be athletic thank you so
much guys for your contribution to the
program and and can't wait to see Orion
and SLS launch
okay so now let's head back over to
Daryl nail over with the launch Team so
we can hear any updates about a new t0
yeah Megan thank you and uh a clear
picture is starting to emerge as the
launch Team now reports out that they
only have a few minutes left of work to
do before they're ready to pick up
polling and uh we're also hearing that
some of that polling which kicks off
with the mission management team is also
now just about three and a half minutes
away
now we are currently still in that hold
but uh the launch Team NASA NASA's test
director is uh continuing to move the
team forward
we've wrapped up work
um on the upper stage
and the lower stage you're looking now
live inside firing room one
we're launch director Charlie Blackwell
Thompson is
overseeing her launch Team
we've had a number of delays that have
put us off the t0
but we are starting to track
to a t0
close to around
a quarter till top of the hour
but we do
need to have some polling
that takes place I'm pausing now because
I'm listening in to the teams as they
communicate
in this launch window which we're
currently
26 minutes into and it's two hours long
it runs until 304 a.m Eastern Time
we have what's called 40 cutouts
and in those cutouts they range from
about a second to about a minute These
are times where they can't launch
these cutouts must be accounted for when
determining a new t0
the upper stage of
the rocket which was the last to get
ready and configured
just recently the team cycled the liquid
hydrogen valves which is required
and they are currently working on the
lo2 valves liquid oxygen valves in the
upper stage that work is almost done
we are now a minute and a half away from
the pole of the mission management team
which is several minutes before
T minus 15 minutes
when that poll starts we'll get a
clearer picture
of our t0
NASA NASA's test director has informed
the launch Team to all switch to a
common Communication channel it's called
230
232
and what this means is
that the entire launch team is now on
one channel
and all future communication will happen
there
whereas there are many channels
now they
reduce it down to one
just heard from NASA test director
Carlos monge
I'm sorry Jeff Spalding Jeff Spalding's
on they swapped out
there are currently no constraints to
Launch
great news again
no constraints to Launch
and they're getting ready to pick up
with a poll
to determine
Readiness for launch
foreign
just Spalding getting ready to conduct
the Readiness poll so we are getting
close
we're going to pull up the audio now
so that you can listen in
please go and rock rock let's go
all right copy all and launch director
entity our launch team is ready to
proceed at this time
I copy all entity at this time I will
proceed with my poll
and attention on 232 this is the launch
director performing the final Poll for
launch verify no constraints and go for
launch EGS program chief engineer
EGS program chief engineer verifies that
the EGS SLS and Orion program Chief
Engineers have no constraints in our go
for launch
copy Greg thank you EGS Chief safety
officer
the EGS CSO verifies the SOS Orion and
egscsos
I have no constraints in our go for
launch
copy John thank you range weather
has no constraints and weather is go for
launch
copy lwo and Mission manager
and Mission manager launch director
launch director Mission manager on 232
the mission management team has been
pulled you have a go to proceed with
terminal account and launch of Artemis
one
all right copy all thank you
and into the launch director
go ahead one instructor
yes sir
on behalf of all the men and women
across our great nation who have worked
to bring this Hardware together to make
this day possible and for the Artemis
generation this is for you
at this time I give you a go to resume
count and launch Artemis one
copy launch director and thank you
all right we do have a couple of steps
to configure and then we will be ready
to resume the clock cvse NTD cvsc here
initiate recording of Orion cameras at
this time in work
our NTD rsr here perform the booster
ignition sna arm rotation enable
NDT rsr booster ignition sna arm and
rotation enable is complete and I copy
thank you
okay so there you heard the poll from
launch director
early
getting ready to get that new t0 time
the poll that you heard was the NASA
test director's poll and all right and
we verified no cutouts at this time and
all Personnel we are going to resume the
clock
GLS you can resume the clock on your
mark TLS copies countdown clock or
resume on my mark
three two one more DLS main line has
been initiated okay T minus ten minutes
and Counting we are T minus ten minutes
away from liftoff of Artemis one as you
can see the clock is now moving let's
put that up
T minus nine minutes and 47 seconds the
L minus
18.6 47 44 is a new lift up time affirm
okay
oh one forty seven forty four one forty
seven a.m eastern time and 44 seconds
foreign
we went straight into terminal count
lift off now nine minutes away
so terminal count
control has been given over to
the GLS the ground launch sequencer a
computer and software that is doing all
of the commanding and monitoring
of the space launch system
we'll hear call outs from the GLS
operator
Alex pandalos
as well as NASA test director Jeff
Spalding
GLS is pre-tensioning the umbilicals at
this very moment you can see them as
they run down the rocket that's getting
them ready to detach
at liftoff those arms will swing away
we'll let go of the rocket in a
clockwise Direction
T minus eight minutes and Counting
the GLS is a
performing up to a hundred commands per
second
including configuring ground systems for
power transfer to the rocket
GLS is turning on cameras recording
video inside and outside the crew module
to collect data for engineers
purging the outskirt booster with high
flow nitrogen
clear out any hydrogen gas that may be
there
you can see the crew access arm is
already retracted
when there is crew during Artemis 2
it would happen at T minus six minutes
but out of abundance of caution they
went ahead and retracted the arm well
ahead of liftoff
want to point your attention to the base
of the mobile launcher something wasn't
done to reduce the power from the
pressure caused by the Rocket's ignition
and thunderous sound it could damage the
rocket so the ignition over pressure and
sound suppression system will flood the
mobile launcher with water
you'll see that sequence start at T
minus 17 seconds
now coming up in less than 30 seconds
the ground launch sequencer will start
bringing the high energy systems online
starting with core stage pressurization
fire number one is
completely silent
as they listen for the next call
gls's go for core stage tank
pressurization
the core stage tank is now pressuring
pressurizing to flight levels
the replenish valve to the liquid
hydrogen tank now closing
the liquid oxygen tank will come a
little later
now we're arming your the Orion ascent
pyros and transfer to internal power
we'll launch a board system or Las
jettison motor is now armed on this
flight the abort motor is inactive
because there is no crew on board up
next is the flight termination system
or FTS which gives the space force the
ability to destruct the rocket if it
goes in the wrong direction let's listen
in for that
DLS go for FPS arm
the flight termination system is now
armed
coming up at four minutes and 40 seconds
a big moment this is where the rs-25
engines
and their bleed go to high flow it's
been a little tricky to dial in
PLS go for lh2 high flow bleed check
good word we've passed that
the cryo team got the lh2 engine bleed
pressure Loop dialed in
they are now at the right temperature
for launch countdown continues
T-minus four minutes 15 seconds
up next GLS fires up the capoos those
are high-speed turbines which provide
pressure to hydraulic pumps that steer
the rs-25s
stands for core stage auxiliary power
unit start
dls's go for core state jpu starts
that now leads to the thrust vector
control test at T minus two minutes and
30 seconds that can proceed now and we
will see
the engine's gimbal at the bottom of the
core stage
at T minus three minutes and 10 seconds
you will hear the go for Purge sequence
four that's a helium Purge of the four
core stage engines Downstream of the
propellant valve getting the air and
moisture out
gls's go for part sequence four
and in just a few seconds GLS will close
the core stage locks vent liquid oxygen
the white Vapor Cloud caused the super
cold gaseous oxygen condensing the water
in the atmosphere will disappear you see
it coming out there now
and there it goes it's closed locks vent
closed pressure rising in the core stage
locks tank to flight levels
coming up in 15 seconds look for that
thrust vector control actuator test
engines will gimbal
and there they go
the four core stage rs25 engines
gimbaling around testing the ability to
steer the rocket into space
they will operate at 109 performance
each rs-25 thrown down a half million
pounds of thrust all four two million
pounds all together with the boosters
8.8 million pounds of thrust PLS for
upper stage to internal power now the
upper stage has gone to internal power
so power is removed from the Rocket's
upper stage the icps and it's been
switched to battery power
the same Milestone is coming up for the
core stage at T minus one minute and 30
seconds
GLS go for core stage to internal power
the Rocket's core stage which houses the
three flight computers is now on battery
power so there is no more hold time
available because there's no more margin
on the batteries so if we hold have a
hold we'd have to recycle back to T
minus 10 minutes and recharge those
batteries
the count continues
a note now shortly after liftoff
one minute shortly after liftoff Mission
Control Houston will take control of the
rocket and my colleague Leah Cheshire
will take over commentary T-minus 50
seconds and counting
coming up at T's minus 33 seconds the
GLS will hand off control to the ALS
this is the autonomous launch sequencer
on board the rocket it will take over
command and control of the rocket but
the ALS will check make sure there's no
holds coming from the ground up until T
minus two go for ALS and we are go for
ALS the space launch system is now
counting down to liftoff of Orion on its
maiden voyage to the Moon
launch Team can no longer recycle the
count
ER pressure water now flowing under the
ml
and here we go
and hydrogen burnoff igniters initiate
seven six five four stage engines start
three two one booster's indignation
and liftoff of Artemis one we rise
together back to the moon and Beyond
all four rs25 engines on the core stage
and two solid rocket boosters now
propelling the vehicle at 128 miles per
hour
very good good control on the role from
teams in Mission Control Houston all
good calls so far now 30 seconds into
the flight Marcus one
first Milestone will be fourth to be
able to pass the max Q in about one
minute and nine seconds into launch this
is the greatest period of atmospheric
force on the rocket
SLS now traveling 607 miles per hour
a million pounds of Maximum thrust quiet
here
in the loop submission control
four stages of throttling down I had to
pass
now one minute 21 seconds into the
flight traveling at 1 420 miles per hour
the four core stage engines are back at
maximum thrust
the next major Milestone will be for the
solid rocket boosters to cut off and
jettison in about two minutes and 11
seconds into the flight so about 30
seconds from now
again quiet here in Mission Control
Houston as teams continue monitoring the
flight of Artemis one
we're now 16 miles downrange from the
launch pad at Kennedy Space Center
traveling over 2 800 miles per hour
standing by for solid rocket booster
jettison and shortly thereafter
confirmation that the solid rocket
boosters have separated these 177-foot
boosters
now the core stage continues to power
the flight of Orion all Force rs-25
engines firing traveling over 3 400
miles per hour 46 miles downrange
two minutes and 36 seconds into the
flight
hearing nominal calls here in Mission
Control Houston
we've still got four good engines on the
core stage next up we'll be looking for
the service module fairing to separate
this is three 15 by 15 foot fairing
panels providing structural support
protecting the service module those will
separate it about 3 minutes and 11
seconds into flight and very shortly
thereafter will be followed by the
launch abort system separation
just over three minutes into the flight
of Artemis 1 now traveling over 4060
miles per hour 83 miles downrange
we just had confirmation that the
service module fairing has separated
and that the launch abort system pyros
have fired separating those from Orion
as well
for future crew members
[Music]
we just heard the call for three engine
press meaning if SLS were to lose an
engine at this point in the mission we
could still achieve a nominal Mission we
would just have an extended main engine
cut off time however we still have four
good engines all at maximum thrust right
now powering the first flight of Artemis
at 5200 miles per hour 148 miles
downrange
we're four minutes and 16 seconds into
the flight of Artemis 1
. so far we've had a clean Ascent we saw
those solid rocket boosters jettison
about two minutes and 11 seconds after
liftoff shortly after we had the service
module parent panels fairings separate
as well as the launch abort system the
launch abort system was inert for this
flight except to perform this separation
those four core stage engines will
continue to Fire and power the flight of
Artemis one now traveling over 6 800
miles per hour 229 miles downrange
booster flight controller reports that
the engines are looking good
our core stage main engine cutoff time
is about 8 minutes and three seconds we
are now at 5 minutes and 11 seconds into
the flight 70 7 656 miles per hour
again four good core stage engines those
four rs-25 engines
the last time those core stage engines
flew they were taking space shuttles to
orbit now with upgraded capabilities
they're launching the future of human
space flight
five minutes and 42 seconds into the
mission we are now traveling 8 800 miles
per hour 345 miles downrange from the
launch pad at Kennedy Space Center
again we are anticipating core stage
main engine cut off at about eight
minutes and three seconds and about 10
seconds later we'll see core stage
separation at which point Orion and the
interim cryogenic propulsion stage will
be flying free
now traveling over 10 000 miles per hour
6 minutes and 15 seconds into the flight
of Artemis 1 427 miles downrange quiet
here on the loops in Mission Control
Houston teams continue to monitor this
first flight
about a minute and a half now until that
core stage main engine cut off time our
four core stage engines continue to fire
maximum thrust
coming up on seven minutes since launch
today now traveling over 12 800 miles
per hour 563 miles downrange again still
quiet here in Mission Control Houston
as we prepare for main engine cutoff the
four rs-25 engines are beginning to
Throttle Down
30 seconds now until core stage main
engine cut off all four engines continue
to Throttle Down
now seven minutes 45 seconds into the
flight traveling over 16 000 miles per
hour
continuing to hear good calls here in
Mission Control Houston
we're standing by for core stage main
engine cut off
and we have confirmation of course stage
main engine cutoff Orion and it's now in
Earth's orbit
the flight Dynamics officer reports that
we have a nominal main engine cutoff
and we just heard the call for core
stage separation that means Orion and
the inner random cryogenic propulsion
stage are now flying free from the core
stage of the space launch system the
next Milestone will be solar array
deploy approximately 18 minutes after
liftoff but before Orion stretches its
wings let's check back in with our
friends at Kennedy Space Center and hear
all about what it was like to hear the
rocket Roar off the launch pad Megan and
Kayla I've got to hear all about it well
if you're just joining us welcome to
NASA's Kennedy Space Center where we
just watched Artemis 1 launch our first
step towards our next adventure into
deep space as Leah said I'm NASA's Megan
Cruz and this is NASA astronaut Kayla
Varan and I'm kind of still giddy and
speechless I don't even know how to
explain how I'm feeling right now I feel
the same way this is the first launch
that I've been able to watch in person
and I've got to say it was incredible I
was just took my breath away and I was
tearing up just what an amazing
accomplishment for this team this
international team people who have been
dedicating their careers to getting this
rocket off the ground and taking the
first step to getting a crew on that
vehicle back to the Moon it was just
incredible yeah this is a moment I think
that we're all gonna remember where we
were when we saw this sort of thing you
know what I mean and it was great to see
again when we entered into terminal
account everybody here just started
cheering you know coming out to get a
really good view and boy I mean it lit
up the night sky and it just shook
everything around us did you feel that
like in my bones I felt that oh yeah the
I mean the cool thing is just kind of
the delay between what you see it is
here because of course the sound travels
a little bit slower and it was just
amazing the the ground shook we could
hear the thrust pushing that rocket into
space 8.8 million pounds of thrust yes
it's incredible it was amazing to see
here live in person how does it compare
so this is your first launch on the
ground how does it compare to your
launch when you're in the capsule
soaring towards space I mean equally
emotional I think one that we train for
everything and so when we're in that
capsule waiting for launch we're just
running our procedures you could almost
you know trick us and say that we were
in the simulator and it wasn't real but
like in that moment of liftoff when the
thrust builds underneath you like we saw
it today it's just hard not to be
overwhelmed by the emotional experience
the excitement the joy of that moment
it's incredible yeah I I think we can't
say it enough this team really deserved
this moment they've been working so hard
for this moment when I heard that we got
into terminal count it was I felt a
sense of relief and excitement for them
that I think everybody here did you know
we really wanted them to succeed we
really wanted to see the launch today
and wow I I will never forget this me
neither it was an incredible experience
to be here and see that happen yeah was
there anything that was particularly
surprising to you again this is your
first launch you know what were you
expecting
you know I think we also had a nighttime
launch for our launch and so I I think
one thing you underestimate is how much
it lights up the nights yeah why we were
able to watch it all the way through
that trajectory we were able to see the
boosters separate and everything so it
was just an incredible view it's amazing
how much you get to see of the flight
path when it's at night and sliding up
the sky yeah and I don't know if you
noticed this but we see the moon here
and it and the trajectory of the rocket
looked like it was flying towards me you
know what I mean I was like oh my God
that's so poetic it's so beautiful I'm
so glad we launched today yeah wow
congratulations to the team it's
incredible we're gonna head over to
Daryl who was at the launch Team Daryl
you got to count us down through that uh
uh through liftoff I mean how was that
being in the launch launch uh control
center with them
well Megan it was uh it was something
else I got to tell you you're looking
live inside the firing room where
Charlie Blackwell Thompson is about to
address her team after a whole lot of
hard work and preparation to get to this
moment let's Stand By and listen to her
now
Comcheck
you can't hear it in the room
can you guys hear me
you can hear me
because the guys
I don't know what he's telling me to do
week
is here
can you guys hear me oh there we go
is he ready for me
[Music]
well for once I might be speechless
so you guys know I have talked a lot
about appreciating the moment that
you're in and we have worked hard as a
team you guys have worked hard as a team
for this moment this is your moment
all right
it is not by chance that you are here
today
so I want you to look around look around
at this team
and know that you have earned it you
have earned your place in the room
you've earned this moment you have
earned your place in history
you were part of a first then come along
very often
once in a career Maybe
but we are all part of something
incredibly special the first launch of
Artemis
the first step in returning our country
to the Moon
and on to Mars
[Applause]
what you have done well what you have
done today will inspire generations to
come
so thank you thank you for your
resilience
you know I said at the pre-test briefing
the heart of the climb the better The
View
we showed the Space Coast tonight what a
beautiful view it is
so congratulations
[Applause]
so we got a couple of traditions here in
launch control
and the first one is
when you're in the position for the
first time
you get a tie cutting
and so I
I have my
launch director scissors
and I'm going to get my tie cut by a
couple of Legends that are here
and then anyone who wants their tie cut
will be making the rounds in the firing
room you got your console Chiefs if they
want to do it that's fine if you want me
to do it you might have to wait a little
while but I'll stay all night if I have
to it'll be my pleasure to cut ties
so I'm gonna get gonna take care of mine
and then I have one other presentation
that I want to make this evening
hey
this is Charlie Blackwell Thompson
Artemis one launch director she just got
her tie cut that is a tradition here at
NASA
we just got to hear her talk to the team
and one thing that really stuck out to
me that she said is that they really
earned their place in history we're
coming up on solar array deploy let's go
on to Leah
thanks Megan and yes we're here in
Mission Control Houston still monitoring
the Artemis One mission and the first
flight of Orion atop the space launch
system so far we saw successful liftoff
at 1 47 a.m eastern time all the way
through separation from the core stage
we now have Orion and the interim
cryogenic propulsion stage flying free
and we've just heard that we have
initiated solar array deploy so we are
turning our Focus to that the spacecraft
was running on battery power but
stretching These Wings will allow it to
stop relying on those batteries and
significantly extend the time it can
stay in space
so solar array deploy takes about 12
minutes we have four solar arrays that
we need to deploy and latch these will
provide power to the spacecraft on its
journey to distant retrograde orbit and
all the way back to earth once these are
properly configured again Orion will no
longer need to rely solely on battery
power
and we expect this to be done about 30
minutes after liftoff right now we're 19
minutes since liftoff today Orion is now
traveling 17
175 miles per hour
we're continuing to hear good calls here
in Mission Control Houston from the
flight controllers monitoring the
mission
a little bit about these solar arrays as
we wait again we heard the call that the
deploy has been initiated we'll hear a
little bit more about that once they
start to unfold these four solar arrays
generate 11 kilowatts of power which is
enough electricity to power two three
bedroom houses and they have a wingspan
of 63 feet just one of these six and a
half by six and a half foot panels has
uh
1250 solar cells so you're looking at a
total of 15
000 solar cells
now we just heard the call that all four
solar arrays have been released so we
initially heard the initiation call that
command had been sent now those four
solar arrays are released again this is
about a 12 minute process
the solar arrays will deploy straight
and you're getting a live view right now
this is really exciting they'll
eventually be swept back against the
vehicle prior to translunar injection
burned to prevent any loads from
breaking or damaging the arrays and on
the end of each solar array is a camera
that will capture imagery for us
throughout the mission along with a few
other cameras placed outside and inside
the spacecraft to help us Monitor and
perform various other inspections
of course if you recall the Apollo
capsule design there were no solar
arrays we had fuel cells instead so this
design with arrays gives us the
opportunity to stay in orbit longer
since we practically have no limit to
the energy available for use from the
Sun
coming up on 21 minutes since liftoff
Orion is attached to the interim
cryogenic propulsion stage you can see
those four solar arrays unfolding now
and again Artemis one is a flight test
it's Paving the way for a sustainable
Presence at the Moon looking forward to
the future Gateway will be our space
station and lunar orbit and we have some
similarities and differences in the
solar arrays unfolding right now on
Orion and those that will be on Gateway
so like we're seeing now these are
deploying autonomously the Gateway solar
arrays will as well
and while these generate those 11
kilowatts of power the two roll out
solar arrays or Rosas on Gateway will
generate 60 kilowatts of power that Rosa
design is currently being tested aboard
the space station we have two new ones
installed and a spacewalk conducted
earlier today preparing for another set
coming up on 22 minutes since liftoff
today Orion and the interim cryogenic
propulsion stage traveling over 16 800
miles per hour
the solar arrays deploying now are part
of the European service module it's
comprised of 20 000 parts and components
the service module was developed as part
of an agreement between NASA and the
European Space Agency or ESA
this is the first time NASA is using a
european-built system as a critical
element to power an American spacecraft
particularly
coming up now in 24 minutes into the
flight of Artemis one spacecraft now
traveling at sixteen thousand five
hundred miles per hour around the earth
we are in solar array deploy and we have
confirmation all four arrays are
deployed
coming up in a little less than 30
minutes as the perigee Rays maneuver
and with our launch at 141 eastern time
this morning we are looking for a
perigee Rays maneuver about 53 minutes
into today's flight again we are now 25
minutes and 47 seconds into the flight
and we have a complete deployment of all
four solar arrays
Orion's Journey To The Moon continues as
planned again looking forward to that
perigee raised maneuver that'll be
coming up again at about 53 minutes into
the mission so about 27 minutes from now
during the pair of G Rays maneuver the
interim cryogenic propulsion stage will
use its rl-10 engine to lift the lowest
point of Orion in Earth's orbit the
current orbit is more of an oval shape
than a perfect circle and this burn will
raise that point closest to Earth and
make the orbit more circular this will
also include a checkout of Orion's
systems and any adjustments to the solar
arrays it'll be a short burn less than
30 seconds long but critical to keep us
on track and it also prepares us for the
next engine burn to send Orion to the
Moon that's the translunar injection
burn that'll come up a little later
which is a longer burn another firing of
the rl-10 engine on the interim
cryogenic propulsion stage
we caught a glimpse there of those solar
arrays and with all four solar arrays
properly deployed Orion's Journey To The
Moon continues and we've got more
operational updates coming up shortly
but for now I'm going to toss it back to
Megan and Kayla at Kennedy
Leah thank you so much our return to the
moon will be different than the last
time we plan to explore more of the
lunar surface and learn how to live and
work there with more on our destination
let's bring back NASA's Dan Hewitt with
our new moon board
hey thanks Megan I I gotta be honest we
ran outside to catch it I'm still
shaking a little bit that that never
gets old that is always one of the
coolest things you'll ever see in your
entire life and that rocket was massive
and loud and just
the so cool all right
the moon this is why we call it the moon
board but the moon you know since the
dawn of time humans have looked at the
sky and shouted at our neighbor I'm
gonna walk in your face
and in the 60s we actually did it uh six
times starting with Neil Armstrong Buzz
Aldrin Apollo 11 1969 followed by five
more successive Landings each time
delivering two human beings to the
surface of the Moon our last one was
Apollo 17 and that was in 1972 Gene
cernan and Harrison Smith stepping off
for the last time now we have not sent
humans back since then but they
accomplished a lot under Apollo lots of
technological advancements deployed
science instruments brought back
hundreds of pounds of lunar rocks and
regula teaching us about the moon and
also about our place in the solar system
the Moon is fascinating because it
doesn't have a lot of the geological
processes we have here on Earth you
don't have erosion you don't have wind
and water wearing Down rocks you don't
have plate tectonics that are constantly
recycling the crust and so everything
out there is really old in fact one of
the Rocks brought back on Apollo 15 team
called the Genesis Rock was dated to be
4 billion years old so from the
primordial beginnings of our solar
system but as Kayla said a little bit
earlier those missions were measured in
days their spacewalks in just hours with
Artemis were looking to go and we're
looking to stay and we're not looking
around the equator like our under Apollo
we're looking at the lunar South Pole
now why so we haven't sent people since
the 70s to the moon but we haven't
stopped studying it we've had orbiters
like the lunar reconnaissance Orbiter
which has literally just been flying
loops around the Moon taking high
resolution images of the surface so high
resolution that you can look them up
they have images of all the different
Apollo Landing sites and you can
actually see the footprints the paths
they left in the lunar regolith of those
sites we had a mission called L cross
which slammed a probe into a crater on
the moon sending out material some of
which potentially hadn't seen direct
sunlight for billions of years and then
analyzing what shot out and through
missions like that and others we've been
able to find that there is water ice
trapped in those permanently shadowed
areas on the moon a lot of them center
around that South Pole we have already
identified 13 potential Landing sites
for the Artemis 3 mission and these are
where we're going to send our astronauts
around the lunar South Pole to access
that water ice now why water why are we
caring about water well it serves a lot
of purposes obviously for humans you
need that to breathe you can split water
apart get oxygen for breathing gas for
an atmosphere if you have a lunar base
you can split it into oxygen and
hydrogen that's Rocket Fuel we just
launched the most powerful rocket in
history using those constituent parts
and so you can start to live off the
land we can use that something called
in-situ resource utilization and and
really the whole point of that is to use
the moon as this Proving Ground we're
trying to get to Mars we're trying to
learn to live on other planets where
there is gravity where we're going to
have to use resources there on the
ground because we won't be able to bring
everything with us and by going to the
lunar South Pole by going to stay under
Artemis we're going to be able to start
practicing that we're going to perfect
those systems perfect those techniques
and operations we need to do that so we
can use the moon as that jumping off
point to Mars and Beyond so
that's why the moon we're going to see
Orion fly around it for the very first
time in just a couple of days that
launched is spectacular I'm still way
too excited uh but can't wait to see
some shots of the Moon from up close
from Orion so I'll send it back over to
you Megan
thanks so much Stan so right now we're
actually joined by members of the red
crew you'll remember from watching the
launch coverage that the red crew was
sent out by the launch Team when the
launch Team identified a small leak on a
hydrogen valve inside of the mobile
launcher well now here they are this is
Trent and it's Pratt can you just uh
introduce everybody else here on your
team yeah so this is Chad he's our
safety guy and behind me is Billy and
he's the experienced hydrogen Tech out
here and the three of you guys really I
I would say save the day today I mean
really you guys had to go in there to
What's called the blast danger zone you
guys are specially trained uh to be able
to do operations on the pad while cryo
is loading talk to us about getting that
call being told hey you guys need to go
in there and it was the first time for
all three of you
yeah all I could say is we were very
excited
I was ready to get up there and go
really how are you guys feeling
very very comfortable very confident in
the test team and the procedures in our
training we we did a great job
walk us oh sorry go ahead how gratifying
it must be for you guys because you you
train for this eventuality but don't
always get to do it Billy was saying
that he's been a red crew team member
for 37 years and this is the first time
he's been called to go into the blast
danger zone so I know for us when we're
training for all of these eventualities
whether it's a spacewalk or robotics
operations you really want to put that
training into practice how do you guys
feel like it went today sure amazing I
still can't believe it
it's surreal to me it's just insane yeah
kind of walk us through what you were
thinking so you get there and and what
is it just like game time and you're
really focused or you know how are you
feeling
yeah I'd say we were we were very
focused on what was happening up there
just making sure
we knew what was happening
because the Rockets you know it's alive
it's creaking it's making venting noises
it's it's pretty scary so on zero deck
my heart was pumping my nerves were
going but
yeah we showed up today I think as soon
as we walked up the stairs we were ready
to rock and roll and they were telling
us a bit about it while you're working
on it you guys were actually just
torquing down at the valve to prevent or
reduce the leak rate or stop the leak is
that right that's right just the packing
gland is a little loose so went up there
and tightened her up
probably still like in this oh my gosh
moment like all of us are you know has
it
act played today in Artemis one launch
you know I still can't believe it like
it's like I said it's surreal and just
amazing
I don't know about you guys but
they're nodding along behind you for
sure uh anything you want to say to the
launch team again this is a big day for
the launch Team for you guys
um NASA but really the whole world I
mean this is a historic launch that I
think we'll all remember uh
we'll all remember really
you know we had a lot of people here
helping us out a lot of teams firing
room I'm sure that was hectic and uh you
know NASA Boeing
all the other companies did a great job
and we're glad to be part of it
I'll push this on our own it takes a
really complex team nobody can be an
expert in all of the systems all the
technology all the workarounds we might
have to do to get a rocket off the pad
so thank you for the role you played in
that team today it's awesome thank you
pleasure yeah thank you so much guys I
appreciate you coming by to talk with us
all right it's now been about 35 minutes
since liftoff of Artemis one Orion and
icps are now free flying so let's head
back to Leah again to talk about how the
journey is going so far
thanks Megan and it has been a pretty
smooth ride so far and uh we are now
again like you mentioned coming up on 36
minutes since launch that puts us about
17 minutes into the perigee until the
Perry G Rays maneuver that's going to be
the maneuver that lifts the lowest point
of Orion's orbit around the Earth and
puts us where we need to be ahead of the
trans lunar injection burn the
translunar injection burn is that really
long burn that we're going to need to
send us on to the moon so we've been
treated to some exciting views from the
spacecraft today including and we hope
to see some from inside the cabin but we
expect to continue receiving photo
updates throughout the mission it takes
a team though to bring the imagery of
Orion down to earth so let's meet them
the imagery they were collecting on
Artemis 1 and the mission itself
is preparing to carry humans to the Moon
the Orion imagery team is going to be
monitoring every aspect of visual
spacecraft performance for the entire
duration of the mission
the first time that we're going to be
live streaming digital video from its
spacecraft back down to the Earth from
the vicinity of the Moon that's never
been done before what will be
transmitting live streaming will be
lower resolution
more compressed because we have to fit
it into a thinner pipe if you will
every one of these cameras is in this
position where it is and it's configured
the way it is for a very specific reason
we're going to be monitoring anything
that we can see with the cameras for
spacecraft performance
the imagery teams at Nasa are composed
of dozens and dozens of very highly
trained very specialized people
Engineers technicians analysts if we can
see it we're going to try and keep an
eye on them imagery has been invaluable
throughout the history of NASA we flew
cameras on Mercury Gemini Apollo all of
that stuff that we saw with the
astronauts around the Moon it helps us
detect the unknown unknowns
allows us to see things that we didn't
anticipate happening before so when we
do flight people on Artemis 2 we can
have a high confidence that everything's
working the way it should
[Music]
I love getting a look at those teams
that we don't normally see like the red
team that Megan and Kayla just got to
interview a really big thanks to them
and everyone that made this liftoff
happen tonight so we are going to toss
it back to Megan and Kayla now at KSC
again we're about 15 minutes away from
perigee race maneuver
thank you Leah yeah we wanted to take us
back into Orion and talk about some of
the science that's being enabled by
Artemis one today so inside of Orion are
10 of these so they're called cubesats
because they're tiny satellites
essentially they're the size of the shoe
box when they're folded down but then
once they're deployed they're opened up
they have solar arrays things like that
that's when it gets a lot bigger now
these are called secondary payloads for
this Mission Kayla can you talk to us
about what secondary payloads are yeah
it just really means that it's not a
primary objective of the mission it's
not we're not relying on the success of
these cubesats or overall mission
success it's kind of a bonus payload
right a chance to deploy these
satellites that have different sensors
on them and collect some awesome data to
support other research objectives yeah
and I know battery life was a concern
for some of them but all 10 were
deployed and scientists I'm sure are
eager to see what kind of information
that hopefully they'll be able to get
and they're just some of several
research projects on this flight that
will help gather data about the moon and
more
Artemis one is Paving the way for us to
explore deeper and deeper into space I
think Artemis one is significant on so
many levels it is a new frontier to do
science so the primary objective is to
test the Orion spacecraft integrated
with the space launch system and it is
designed to to carry out the the boldest
of the Bold missions but it's more than
just learning how to travel in space
we're taking a lot of cool science along
with us on this first mission to the
moon so as NASA plans to go back to the
surface of the Moon and then on to Mars
we want to spend more time there and
that's riskier business so the more we
learn about the moon itself and the
environment where we'll be operating the
better we can prepare we have 10
cubesats we call secondary payloads
which are small scientific spacecraft of
their own that will each be conducting
their own scientific Mission all of
these payloads in some form or fashion
will help us going forward they are
going to be studying the Moon and
they're going to help us understand what
is the moon made out of what types of
rocks what types of regolith what types
of ice what's mixed in with water that
might be present one of them actually is
going to attempt to land on the moon
they're going to be studying the sun
understanding and studying the space
environment or the space weather some
different propulsion systems these novel
ideas will ultimately turn into the
technology and the systems that we want
to use going forward there's a lot of
cool things going on between all these
cubesats that make up our secondary
payloads additionally inside the Orion
will be flying an experiment to study
space biology space biology is where we
study the underlying changes that
earth-based biological systems undergo
when they're in space or basically how
does life respond to the space
environment the level of ionizing
radiation that you experience when you
go beyond the Van Allen belt so you go
beyond the protective magnetic sphere
that we have around us you then get
exposed to higher levels of ionizing
radiation so we are flying several space
biology experiments it will take a
series of materials plant seeds fungi
the yeast cell algae and right along the
trip and then when it comes home we can
analyze how they responded to that
environment This research will help us
thrive in space it will help us to go
further and stay there longer in
addition to space biology we'll be
learning about how to make astronauts
more effective in the Orion in the
future an example of that is something
called the Callisto technology
demonstration Lockheed Martin built the
Orion spacecraft for NASA and we'll be
flying a secondary payload that's a
demonstration payload called Callisto so
we took the technology from Amazon for
Alexa and the WebEx technology from
Cisco and so we built a digital
assistant if you will the custom space
qualified Alexa Alexa how does the life
support system work
Orion's life support system is the
environmental control and life support
system oracles and so this payload is
the demonstration mission to show how
astronauts in the future could use this
technology as an Innovative user
interface so there you have it I hope
you agree with me this is exciting I am
just over the moon excited for the
Artemis one launch the science will
conduct on Artemis 1 lays the groundwork
to ensure that we can safely conduct
scientific activities at the Moon with
our astronauts going forward this really
is the stepping stone for us as we take
that next giant leap in space
exploration
so a lot of great science also happening
on the International Space Station I got
to speak with astronauts Jessica Watkins
and Samantha Christopher Eddie while
they were still on board about the
research there that will benefit future
Artemis missions
Jessica Samantha your primary job on the
space station is to maintain the
orbiting lab and conduct science
experiments more than 200 before crew 4
returns home Jessica can you tell me
about one of the experiments that will
help return us to the Moon with the
Artemis program we do a lot of
experiments where we are looking into
developing new technologies that will
enable us to go further into the solar
system and one of those Technologies was
the Astro rad
experimental radiation is is one of the
challenges that we face when we think
about going further into the solar
system and so this vest is an option for
providing the crew member with
protection and then one of the
mannequins on Artemis one launching here
later this month will also be wearing
the vest we'll get a sense for its
Effectiveness on board as well Samantha
I know that you've been doing a lot of
work to test uh how we would grow crops
in space what crops are you growing on
Space Station right now and what's
unique about them
indeed actually right next to uh to us
as we are talking to you we have a
little space station vegetable garden
it's called X root and in a few weeks it
will be full of fully grown hopefully
tomatoes and carrot plants I don't have
much of a green thumb but it must
confess but when I harvested those
plants and I could really like Breathe
In All That Smell even if there is no
soil it still has that smell that you
would associate on the ground with uh
walking you know through a vegetable
garden after a rainy day you know when
there is that moist that moisture in in
the air and and that was just so so
pleasant after you know such a long time
living away from any kind of natural
environment it was very very pleasant
for me if it makes you feel any better I
also do not have a green thumb
so what about water how are you testing
critical life support systems like water
to hopefully help us stay off Earth
longer than we ever have before sure yes
so um we we kind of use the
um the tagline that um today's
yesterday's coffee becomes today's
coffee so there's a process by which we
can filter our our urine and so we are
at the point now where we are able to
recycle about 96 of the
um essentially of our our water on board
and are continuing to test new
technologies to get even closer to the
98 utilization rate that we'll need for
for the moon in particular Samantha what
are you most excited about for Artemis
one seeing that gigantic rocket take off
and uh I think it would be just uh you
know a sign of of all those great things
to come Jessica you could one day walk
on the moon as part of the Artemis
program how does that make you feel the
idea of being able to explore the the
surface of another planetary body
especially for me as a geologist and a
planetary geologist specifically it's
just super exciting
um all of the the science that we're
going to be able to conduct from the
surface of the Moon Jessica Samantha
thank you so much and before you go I'd
love to see a flip
I love it and a double backflip at that
now Kayla you of course lived and worked
on the International Space Station as
part of crew three uh you know do you
enjoy or did you enjoy doing all those
science experiments while you were there
it's a lot of hard work yeah it's
incredible to be a part of the every
single experiment it's an honor to play
a small role in it we got to do some
really cool Tech demonstrations while we
were up there too so for me as an
engineer that was really fun that's a
photo of me doing the first scanning
electron microscope samples on the
International Space Station and it was
cool for me because I worked with a
scanning electron microscope in my
graduate school research that took up
like it was as big as this desk but
seeing a miniaturized version of those
that we have up there and imagining how
we could use it in a lunar or Martian
laboratory to better analyze samples and
decide what to bring home was really
exciting yeah and you touched on this
earlier before but I I do think it's
just so important to note again that
you're doing science for scientists
who've been working on the their their
studies for decades some of them so to
fulfill that how does that make you feel
it's incredible we're almost like their
laboratory technicians for that little
moment in time you know but they've been
working their entire life sometimes
decades years to get that science
payload up there and it's a really
unique laboratory environment the
microgravity environment the space
environment the radiation environment
like you heard talked about in those
videos provides an opportunity to do
science that we just can't do here on
Earth yeah to think that what we do on
the International Space Station can fuel
future Artemis missions I think the fact
that they go hand in hand is really cool
all right so let's take some more social
media questions uh social media is
buzzing right now since we launched
about 48 minutes ago so why don't we
take the first question I think again
from uh after oh no let's see Kayla how
do you feel after a launch
super inspired I mean
we talked about it earlier with the red
crew and in the moments just after
launch but this is really the
culmination of a giant team effort it
takes every single member of our team to
pull off a successful launch it's
incredibly complicated incredibly
challenging and in some cases kind of
dangerous for a red crew team who inside
the blast danger area to make a fix that
was critical today's launch and so to
see the team succeed and feel that
excitement was incredible I really still
have um Charlie Blackwell Thompson's
words ringing in my head the fact that
she said the harder the climb the better
the view 100 correct
all right next question is from actor
Jack Black he starred in a movie called
uh Apollo 10 and a half he has a
question for Kayla
okay Jack's final question I promise
let's talk about Orion
how long will it take for Orion to fly
around the moon and come home and what's
that re-entry going to be like it sounds
like it might be a little hot
coming in hot
you're exactly right jack it is a 26 day
mission that we have planned for Artemis
where it will go to the moon go into a
distant retrograde orbit so we'll get a
few close flybys and then some time in
deep space past the moon and then yeah
that re-entry is going to be something
else it's going to be 5 000 degrees
Fahrenheit super hot and so we'll be
looking at how the heat shield performs
just to ensure that I'll be able to
protect the crew for that speed and
temperature that's half as hot as the
sun yes it's incredibly hot so we rely
on that heat shield to keep our systems
and our crews safe but we expect that
it'll perform well but we're excited to
see how it it does in about 26 days okay
one last question from social media
what qualifications are required to
become an astronaut
um you have to study stem you have to
have a master's degree or higher in a
stem field but besides that we're
looking for people who are awesome team
players so there's a lot of different
roads to become an astronaut we seem to
be getting a lot of questions about how
people themselves can become astronauts
I think that's really cool that we might
see and Inspire again people who might
think about becoming astronauts
absolutely okay well thank you Kayla and
thank you for those who sent in those
questions we are about 50 minutes after
the launch of Artemis one and we are
approaching the next critical Milestone
that's perigee Rays maneuver so let's
head back over to Leah and Mission
Control
thanks Megan and you're right we are
coming up on perigee Ray's maneuver
about two minutes from now we are now 51
minutes into the flight of Artemis one
after lifting off at 1 47 a.m eastern
time from Kennedy Space Center the
vehicle now traveling over 14 600 miles
per hour so during Orion's orbit of
Earth it reaches an apogee and a perigee
the apogee is the highest point above
Earth's surface and the perigee is the
lowest therefore this perigee raised
maneuver is a firing of the icps rl-10
engine and it's going to raise the
lowest point of Orion's orbit over Earth
this also included a checkout of Orion's
systems and any adjustments to the solar
arrays all four of those solar arrays as
you can see are swept back that's going
to keep them from having any loads
imparted that might damage them for use
later in the mission this also the
perigee raised maneuver will put us in
the proper position for the translunar
injection burn that's that really big
and long burn that we need to send us to
the Moon
we're about one minute away from the
perigee Rays maneuver this is a shorter
burn it's less than 30 seconds
about 45 seconds until the perigee Rays
maneuver
coming up on 53 minutes into today's
Mission and we are standing by for the
start of the perigee Rays maneuver again
this is a firing of the rl-10 engine on
the interim cryogenic propulsion stage
it's less than 30 seconds long
and we have confirmation of perigee
Ray's maneuver ignition and full thrust
this is a live view from the spacecraft
again a really short burn we're standing
by for the cutoff
and we have confirmation of perigee
raised maneuver cut off
flight Dynamics officer reporting on the
loops here at Mission Control Houston
that it was a good burn we are now 54
minutes into the flight Orion traveling
14 700 miles per hour and that was the
perigee raised maneuver lifting the
lowest part of Orion's orbit around the
Earth and putting us right where we want
to be for the trans lunar injection burn
we're looking for that translunar
injection burn to happen about 1 hour
and 26 minutes after launch so about 30
minutes from now that'll be that long
burn that helps us break free from the
pull of Earth's gravity and commits the
spacecraft to a lunar trajectory so with
successful completion of the pairs you
raise maneuver I'm going to toss it back
to Megan at KSC
test I hope you didn't miss it but if
you did we have a quick replay of the
launch here
sounds of pressure water now flowing
under the ml
and here we go
hydrogen burnoff igniters initiate seven
six five four stage engine start three
two one booster's indignation
and liftoff of Artemis one we rise
together back to the moon and Beyond
R4 rs25 engines on the core stage and
two solid rocket boosters now propelling
the vehicle at 128 miles per hour
hearing good good control on the role
from teams in Mission Control Houston
all good calls so far now 30 seconds
into the flight Artemis one
first Milestone will be forward the
vehicle to pass through Max Q in about
one minute and nine seconds into launch
this is the greatest period of
atmospheric force on the rocket
SLS now traveling 607 miles per hour
you're looking at 8.8 million pounds of
Maximum thrust quiet here
in the loops in Mission Control
the four core stage engines are
throttling down ahead of passing through
Now to celebrate Artemis one's
successful liftoff is NASA administrator
Bill Nelson administered you gotta share
what you just told Kayla and I you said
that that was the biggest flame you've
ever seen that's that's the biggest
flame I've ever seen it's the most
acoustical Shockwave that I had ever
experienced we were out on the roof of
the launch control center and I'm
telling you
you definitely knew that there was some
energy being expended over there
yeah what does it mean to you to be the
leader of our Organization for a
historic launch like this we've been
talking about the team it takes to get
this done how does it feel to be at the
helm of that ship well I got to talk to
the launch control center team
and I said to them you all are a part of
a great legacy that has been many many
years coming
a lot of Sweat and Tears
and this Legacy is now taking us as we
explore the heavens
and um
it didn't end with Apollo 17. but this
time we're going back
and we're going to learn a lot of what
we have to and then we're going to Mars
with humans why is it such a priority
for the agency to land the first woman
and first person of color on the moon
through this Artemis program well I
think it's reflective of us
it's reflective of America
we are people
our Latin emblem is e pluribus unum in
the uh in the chamber of the United
States Senate over that main door is e
pluribus unum out of many one and so our
astronaut core
reflects that
and it's going to be uh the first boots
back on the moon are going to be the
first woman and the next man
yeah and another goal of the Artemis
program is to support Economic
Development can you talk to us about how
this program has been able to do that
for the country well if you put it in
NASA's economic report terms
it's billions of dollars affecting the
economy almost 400 000 jobs but that's
just direct think of all the indirect
uh
expenditures that are causing the
economy to rise and more jobs for
example what you guys are doing on the
station a lot of your research take for
example the pharmaceutical research
you're helping already One Drug that's
being manufactured on Earth better
because of what you learned in space and
that drug is attacking cancer now what's
the value of that that's just additional
value that is added
I remind everybody in everybody's pocket
they've got a cell phone and that's got
a camera
and that's a camera on a chip that came
out of the NASA space program that's
right I was absolutely in addition to
those Innovative new technologies and
the economic impact I think for me
seeing this launch today it's so
palpable just that human desire to
explore what do you think about what
we're doing to inspire the Artemis and
the generations to follow us well I
think all you have to do is walk into a
classroom of kids and look how their
eyes get big when you start talking
about space
and that is going to multiply itself
many fold as we go back to the moon and
then on to Mars uh it's also going to
bring about a new generation of
Engineers and mathematicians and
technologists
and scientists and all the benefits of
that additional
activity and education coming out of the
Artemis generation
look what that's going to do for our
country and our economy as well as for
our International partners
and uh
it's a great day
I couldn't have said a better myself
administrator thank you so much for
joining us for this momentous occasion
as you said this is the beginning of a
new age in space exploration thank you
so much thank you ma'am and Kayla that's
going to do it for us here at the host
desk uh launch was just the first step
in a nearly 26 day Mission our
colleagues in Houston will now continue
the broadcast to bring you the next big
milestone to the Moon from Kayla and me
have a great day and go Artemis one go
Artemis
and we had a great ride to orbit today
we are now one hour and two minutes
since we launched the Artemis 1 Mission
Orion is traveling with the interim
cryogenic propulsion stage now almost 15
000 miles per hour we recently saw the
perigee raised maneuver that's where we
lifted the lowest point of Orion's orbit
around the Earth and it puts us in the
perfect position to repair us for
translunar injection burn coming up in
about 25 minutes
so again we are looking forward to that
translunar injection burn that's what
it's going to commit us to our journey
to the moon and to tell us a little bit
more about the translunar injection burn
we've got Dan Hewitt standing by to show
us on the moon board how it's all going
to go down
hey thanks Leah everybody Welcome Back
To The Moon board so trans lunar
injection this is the big one just a
refresher we're going to be using this
the interim cryogenic propulsion stage
this is what's taken over for all of our
in-space propulsion Maneuvers after that
core stage and those boosters have Sims
dropped away modified every stage from
the Delta IV family Rockets from United
launch Alliance hydrogen oxygen fueling
the rl-10b-2 engine produces about 24
000 pounds of thrust in a vacuum now the
trans lunar injection is what's going to
give us the energy to go from low earth
orbit all the way out here now what does
that mean here comes a really overly
simplified orbital mechanics lesson
let's say you're in orbit around a
planet say Earth and you're in a nice
circular orbit but you want to have that
orbit be even higher but what you can do
is fire your engine behind you increase
your speed and that then increases the
corresponding apogee are the highest
point of your Orbit on the other side
and that's how you raise it up well if
you wanted to make it into a nice Circle
you could follow up and do another burn
right here and that would raise your
perigee or your lowest point and then
you're in a circular orbit around Earth
that's essentially called a Homen
transfer if you've ever followed our
missions to the space station that's
what we're doing to kind of gradually
raise our orbit until we get to the
space station but for this we're talking
about a lot more energy to get somewhere
a lot farther away so what we're
essentially doing is we're going to be
in this circular orbit around planet
Earth and we are going to be firing that
engine with 24 000 pounds of thrust for
about 18 minutes and what that does is
it doesn't just increase your apogee by
a little it increases it all the way out
and it's timed so by the time Orion is
hitting its apogee the highest point of
that orbit the Moon will have moved into
position that you're entering into its
fear of influence you're entering into
that area where the lunar gravity is
going to be able to capture you and so
that's why we're firing the engine for
that long we need to have that much
thrust that much time to get the energy
to go out there so that's the rough
orbital mechanics of what we're doing
now after that tli burn is done the icps
is going to separate its job largely
done in the Artemis One mission as we
heard it's got some secondary payloads
up in this stage adapter here that it's
going to deploy on its way out the icps
will have one more burn after tli called
the disposal burn and what that's going
to do is put it on a trajectory almost
looking parallel to that of Orion where
it's going to go around the Moon
slingshot away and then go into what's
called a heliocentric orbit it's
actually going to go into orbit around
the sun just like Earth it's going to
leave the Earth Moon system completely
and then after that all of the
propulsion duties get handed over to the
the European service module so it'll be
using its engines it's going to do the
outbound trajectory correction burn at
least the first one on flight day one
and a couple more until we get out to
the moon and get ready to head into
distance retrograde orbit so that's tli
it's coming up next it's going to be a
really big moment to pay attention to so
we'll send it back over to Leah to walk
us through the apps Leah
thanks Dan we are one hour six minutes
and 30 seconds into the flight of
Artemis one now traveling over 15 200
miles per hour
again we've recently had the perigee
raised maneuver and in less than 20
minutes now we'll be looking for the
translunar injection burn that Dan just
showcased that's going to send us to the
moon but our mission started off with an
epic show from the space launch system
again the space launch system is what
carried us into orbit today launching
off at 1 47 a.m eastern time and we've
got a couple of special guests from
Marshall space flight center we have a
Bruce tiller the solid rocket booster
manager and Johnny Heflin the rs-25
engine manager to tell us more about the
maiden voyage of the rocket now they
both got to watch it live at Kennedy
Space Center so a big high to you Bruce
and Johnny thank you so much for joining
us today
thank you thank you for having us yes
pleasure to be here
and can you tell me a little bit about
SLS performance performance did it
perform as you expected
sure so so I manage the booster part of
the rocket and uh the boosters were
fantastic they performed just as we
expected
um we got to see some of the data
obviously the team hadn't plotted it all
but the pressures look great you know it
it burned for just the right amount of
time and uh the it separated great we
could see that as well so very pleased
we were confident it would work well and
it did very happy
similar story for RS 25 nominal what we
call nominal performance the engines
performed exactly as predicted based on
the quick click data like the booster
we've got a lot of data to look at but
so far the data looks really really good
these historic rs-25s that have 25
flights between them on up coming off
the shuttle program so really looking
forward to getting a look at the data it
looks really good so far
that's fantastic and we agree it was it
was amazing to monitor here and the
loops were very quiet in Mission Control
Houston that was a good sign you knew
that things were going well so we know
that the launch abort system was
inactive for this Mission but it will be
active for when we have crew on board
for Artemis 2. are there any other
differences we can expect to see in the
rocket for Artemis 2. so for the
boosters by and large no if I talk about
the boosters from top to bottom we
didn't we are going to make one change
though because the crew is on it we're
going to have a delay timer in there so
that if for some reason they need to
abort we have a a few seconds there
before after they abort before the the
termination system destroys the rocket
so we will add that but other than that
nope these boosters will be the same
second flight is the first same story
for rs25 it will be in the next set of
four uh Heritage engines from the
shuttle program configuration wise
they'll be the same as what we flew
today
then I'm glad it all went so well and so
after you get that data back from today
what's next for your team
well for my team we've still got a ton
of work to do we're we're not only I
mean we're working on at least three
flight sets at the same time uh and so
we've we've got two and three and four
to work on
um we also are working on a new booster
that's a composite case design that will
replace this steel case version that
we're flying today so so we're excited
about that and there's a lot a lot of
work going on there as well so we've got
a lot to do and we'll just keep doing it
so rs25 super busy as well we have the
Artemis 2 engines have already been
delivered to math and they're on on
schedule to be installed in the Artemis
2 core stage in mid-January
we're also about to start the
certification test series for the new
rs-25 engines that we're building we
have Heritage engines for the first four
flights beyond that coming in on Artemis
five we will fly what we call the rs-25
restart engines that have been
redesigned to reduce cost and
re-establish manufacturing for future
flights so we're really excited to get
into that certification test series
really soon as well
all right well thank you both so much
again for joining us I'm glad that you
got to watch the launch and a major
congratulations to you and your teams
for all of the effort that you've poured
into this go Artemis great day great day
thank you so much
all right and we are now one hour and 12
minutes into the flight of Artemis one
we are traveling at orbital velocity
again Orion is currently attached to the
interim cryogenic propulsion stage which
recently performed the perigee Rays
maneuver and we are standing by for
translunar injection burn now less than
15 minutes away it's going to be about
an 18 minute burn that will commit us to
the Moon
part of the Artemis program's goal is to
inspire the next generation of dreamers
and Explorers so we want to show you
what students are doing right now to
bring the Artemis missions to life
NASA's Artemis Mission will land the
first woman in the first person of
hellert on the moon and today's students
are the Artemis generation
you're a student you can design and
build technologies that support the
Artemis Mission with NASA's Artemis
student challenges no matter your
background or experience you're invited
to choose a challenge that interests you
whether it's Rockets
[Music]
robots
tools
software
[Music]
vehicles
or other Technologies there's an
exciting challenge for you
find a mentor and build a team of
students
yes to life with NASA's Artemis students
visit
stem.nasa.gov Artemis and see how you
can join with NASA's Mission related
student challenges
foreign
seconds since liftoff today we are
looking towards translunar injection
burn now about 13 minutes away that's
going to send us to the moon but did you
know that you were invited to fly on the
first Artemis Mission 2. earlier this
year NASA asked the public to create a
pass to virtually board Orion anyone who
signed up got to include their name on a
flash drive I know my name is on there
and that flash drive is on Orion right
now for its Journey around the Moon it
has more than 3.3 million names
the Orion spacecraft is designed to
carry four crew members to lunar orbit
which we're preparing for on Artemis 2.
NASA astronaut Randy bresnick brought us
through the hatch of the vehicle to show
us where those future crew members will
live and work during their Journey
this is the Orion crew station where the
crew will be when they fly the vehicle
as you can see the commander seats on
the left the pilot seat is on the right
compared to the Space Shuttle which had
over 1200 switches controls and circuit
breakers Artemis astronauts will have
much less only about 63. inside the crew
4 can live and work for up to 21 days at
a time which is several days longer than
the previous crude Apollo missions to
the moon the interior is about 30
percent larger than those Apollo era
capsules to give more crew living in
working space everything crew needs is
packed right under the floor thanks to
the Orion stosh system under these
panels of space for everything ranging
from food clothing sleeping bags to
science and camera equipment and even
the tools necessary to perform repairs
if required on the upper part of the
crew compartment or what we call the
overhead is the docking compartment a
crucial component of future exploration
it allows Crews to dock the Orion
capsule to Gateway NASA's Next
Generation lunar Outpost once they dock
Crews will have the ability to board to
lunar Landers also attached to the
Gateway and then head down to the
surface of the Moon through these
windows the four crew members will have
amazing front row seats on their journey
to and from the Moon do you remember
Apollo 8 and billander's famous photo of
earthrise as they came around the moon
and saw it for the first time imagine
being one of those first crew members on
Orion having their own modern day
earthrise and knowing they are traveling
farther from Earth than humans have ever
traveled before thanks to thousands of
people from across the country and
around the world who have helped with
the research design construction testing
and more testing my fellow astronauts
and I know that whoever gets selected
for future Autumn's missions they're
going to have the Journey of a Lifetime
on board the spectacular vehicle we call
Orion
we're now coming up on 10 minutes until
the translunar injection burn again
Orion is still attached to the interim
cryogenic propulsion stage that rl-10
engine is what's going to perform the
burn for us but to hear more about Orion
I'm going to send it back to Dan at the
Moon board to tell us all about our
spacecraft
hey thanks Leah welcome back to the Moon
board and Orion so it's still attached
to icps still flying on the very upper
part of SLS but pretty soon it's going
to be flying free and after that happens
it's going to take over all of the
propulsion all of the flying everything
for the rest of the mission and so to
talk a little bit more about propulsion
let's focus in on this the European
service module so this is what's going
to be doing all of our Maneuvers after
we're done with icps and the translunar
injection burn and it's going to be
doing that with a mix of three different
types of engines first one here on the
bottom is the large orbital maneuvering
system engine this one produces about
six thousand pounds of thrust that's
going to be doing a lot of your really
major pushing Maneuvers when we get into
the powered flybys the insertion into
distance retrograde orbit that burns to
start sending us back home that's the
one that's really applying the most
force it can also gimbal which
essentially means it can swivel around
and that can help your steering it's
helped out by these eight auxiliary
thrusters they're in pairs those are a
little bit smaller each one of those
produces about 105 pounds of thrust each
but they add some additional push to
that orbital maneuvering system engine
and then we also have 24 reaction
control system thrusters these smaller
ones that you can see all around Orion
those are used for a lot of attitude
control so again which they can help
which way you're pointing but also small
translational Maneuvers so moving side
to side up down those can be called into
play now all of those engines share a
common fuel source they're using what
are called hypergolic fuels a mix of a
fuel and an oxidizer in this case mono
methyl hydrazine and nitrogen tetroxide
now those are long names and they're
hypergolic fuels what does that mean a
hypergolic fuel essentially means you
take your fuel in your oxidizer you put
them together you get a reaction you get
an exothermic reaction which creates
that thrust which comes comes out you
don't need an ignition Source like we
have on SLS which is using oxygen and
hydrogen they're extremely reliable
they're very stable you don't have to
store them at cryogenic temperatures
which is really necessary for smaller
spacecrafts in orbit because it takes a
tremendous amount of electrical energy
just to keep fuels that cold and so we
can store them at a much closer to room
temperature essentially when they're on
board this spacecraft so that's all of
the primary propulsion that's going to
take over and again that's going to be
after we get through translunar
injection we're going to be doing
correction burns on the way out a number
around the Moon as we hang out on
distant retrograde orbit for about a
week and then eventually sending us on
the way back home but still attached to
icps right now going to detach shortly
after that burn is complete and then
Orion will be flying free the service
module pushing it for the rest of the
way so with that send it back over to
Leah's we get close to that tli burn
thank you Dan and yes indeed we are
looking for tli coming up in about seven
minutes from now again that's one of a
long that's a long run for us about 18
minutes long but before we get to that
Milestone I have a friend of mine here
it's Stu McClung the program planning
and control office chief of staff for
the Orion program Stu I am so glad that
you could join us today thank you good
morning good to be here so how is the
spacecraft performing so far and what's
next so so far so well and a good uh we
had good we were clean during the
pre-launch and accents um the teams down
the hall in the mirror taking a look
working everything it looks good so far
so that's good
and of course you know we got the burn
cup
um after the burn we'll start we'll
start ticking through all of our planned
events um like we have a solar or the
the saw modal survey solar the wings
will have a modal survey that we'll do
later this morning one of the main one
of the first dtos that we'll take a look
at evaluate how they how they react
so dto designated test objective what
are maybe not what's another one of
those that we'll be looking at over the
next 26 days oh we have probably a good
hundred of them
um the you know culminate from
everything from like the modal survey to
how the um the the cooling system uh
behaves contract system on Entry day one
of our major test objectives is looking
at how the heat shield and the uh how it
handles entry Heating
so how does it feel to be here today and
see the future of human space
exploration unfold that's great
um I was
I was doing my
doing my shift in the mirror earlier
today
um haven't slept the the emotion and the
the adrenaline's got me going it's great
to be a part of this it was great
watching you're like watching the KSC
team execute and now it's this is day
one for us you know we've got 26 days
for our team to execute now and uh and
we'll go do our job and you know set the
stage for future Artemis uh exploration
and we're excited we're going to be here
along the way for all those major
Milestones Burns uh all the other
exciting events that we are looking
forward to so thank you so much for
joining us here
um we are really excited a big congrats
to you and your team thanks let's go
have a good burn and let's go to the
Moon let's do it we are now uh less than
five minutes away from the trans lunar
injection burn again this is the burn
that's going to send us around them
gonna commit us to a lunar trajectory it
is approximately an 18 minute burn it's
a firing of that rl-10 engine on the
interim project in a propulsion stage
you've got a view here of the white
flight control room in Mission Control
Houston this is where all of the teams
will be monitoring the mission over the
next 26 days teams monitored launch
tonight there are of course several
different shifts that will be working
here
all right we are coming up now on about
three minutes until the translunar
injection burn
again this is about an 18 minute long
burn firing of the rl-10 engine on the
interim cryogenic propulsion stage
commits us to lunar trajectory it helps
us break free from the gravitational
pull of Earth
in case you missed it in June of this
year we launched Capstone a small
satellite launched from New Zealand
designated to designed to test a unique
lunar orbit for our future space station
around the Moon called Gateway and just
two days ago Capstone arrived at its
intended orbit around the moon so we're
very excited for that Milestone it
really helps pave the way for our future
Artemis missions
we are now one hour 20 coming up on 25
minutes since liftoff from Kennedy Space
Center today at 1 47 a.m eastern time we
had a really smooth ride to orbit we saw
solar uh we saw solid rocket booster
jettison as well as launch abort system
jettison eventually we had core stage
separation which put us in the
configuration that we have now with
Orion connected to the interim cryogenic
propulsion stage and flying free the
solar arrays deployed and have been
swept back in preparation for the
translunar injection burn earlier we had
the perigee Rays maneuver which lift to
the lowest part of Orion's orbit around
the Earth put us in this perfect
positioning ahead of translunar
injection burn a good shot here of our
two flight controllers on the left you
saw Judd freeling he is the ascent
flight controller he's been with his
team here for the last several hours and
to his right is Rick labrode he's the
lead flight controller for a majority of
the rest of the mission Judd's team will
take over again once we get back into
the re-entry portion
we're now less than a minute away from
trans lunar injection burn
foreign
view from the spacecraft
you can see from this view we have all
four of those solar array Wings swept
back Orion now traveling off the
northwest coast of Australia towards the
Pacific Ocean this translunar injection
burn will begin to take it away from the
earth breaking it free from the pull of
gravity we're standing by for
confirmation that the burn has started
we have confirmation from the booster
officer that the translunar injection
burn has begun and that we are at
maximum thrust
again this is a long burn about 18
minutes
it commits us to a lunar trajectory
this icps firing now is an rl-10 engine
it's a design that's been around since
the 1960s and it's a proven reliable
engine this single engine has 25 000
pounds of thrust we've already seen the
icps in action today as it powered the
Perry G Rays maneuver just about an hour
ago
and if you look in the background you
can see the sunset
of the Earth this is the closest Orion
will be to the Earth until it begins its
return home
right now we're about 382 miles above
the Earth's surface and to put it into
perspective we are approximately 252
670 miles away from the Moon I'm going
to keep reporting that number and by the
end of the translunar injection burn you
will see that start to decrease we're
going to continue to grow
closer to the moon and further away from
Earth this really helps us break free
from Gravity
now traveling at 17
743 miles per hour we're about a minute
and a half into the burn
and although this is the last burn for
the interim credit propulsion stage
there are other Burns that will take
place throughout the mission to direct
Orion exactly where we want it to be
those include the outbound trajectory
correction burns the first of which will
happen later today we also have the
outbound powered flyby the return
powered flyby and others burns after the
icps separates will be conducted by
using the single main engine on the
service module eight auxiliary thrusters
on the base of the service module or 24
smaller thrusters
coming up on two and a half minutes into
the trans lunar injection burn and we're
now traveling over 18 000 miles per hour
again that speed is going to increase as
well this is really going to push Orion
toward the moon and we are now 252 400
miles away from the Moon
we have 10 cubesats along for the ride
with us today those will be deployed
after this translunar injection burn and
icps separation
these are located inside the Orion stage
adapter and they include the lunar Ice
Cube developed by Morehead State
University in Kentucky this will search
for all forms of water with an infrared
spectrometer Luna map from Arizona State
University will create higher Fidelity
maps of near-surface hydrogen and
craters and other permanently shadowed
regions of the lunar South Pole with
Neutron spectrometers
Alma Tanashi is from the Japanese
Aerospace Exploration Agency which is
also known as jaxa they are developing
the world's smallest lunar lander to
study the lunar environment
and lunar by Lockheed Martin in Colorado
will perform Advanced infrared Imaging
of the lunar surface
now three and a half minutes into the
translator injection burn again it's
about an 18 minute burn traveling 18
560 miles per hour
quiet on the loops here in mission
control as the rl-10 engine continues
doing its job on the interim cryogenic
propulsion stage
we talked about a few of our cubesats we
also have one preparing to study an
asteroid the near-earth asteroid Scout
or nia Scout by Marshall space flight
center in Alabama will travel by solar
sail to a near-earth asteroid to take
pictures of and make other
characterizations of its surface
there's a cubesat on board studying
earth called equilius by the University
of Tokyo along with jaxa in Japan
aquilius stands for equilibrium lunar
Earth 0.6u spacecraft and will travel to
LaGrange Point 2 Imaging Earth's plasma
Sphere for a better understanding of our
planet's radiation environment
we're now coming up on 4 minutes and 45
seconds into the translunar injection
burn Orion traveling at 18
982 miles per hour
our distance from the Moon continues to
decrease now 251 900 miles away
to highlight some more of our cubesats
on board we also have biosentinal
developed by Ames Research Center in
California and we'll use a single yeast
cell to detect measure and compare the
impact of deep space radiation on living
organisms over an extended period of
time
Argo moon was developed by the Italian
space agency and argotech in Italy this
cubesat will observe the interim
cryogenic propulsion stage the stage
that it's firing right now with its
Advanced Optics and software Imaging
system and our last cubesat through the
Centennial challenge is 10 miles from
Florida who developed a cubesat that
will demonstrate propulsion using plasma
thrusters and will compete in NASA's
deep space derby
these cubesats pack a ton of tech and
Science in a tiny package so they don't
all have redundant systems and if any of
the cubesats missions don't go as
planned it does not affect our primary
objectives of Orion's Mission this ride
share opportunity is a rare chance to
send cubesats belong Beyond low earth
orbit and we're looking forward to
seeing what we learn
we're now six minutes into the
translunar injection burn Orion
traveling at 19 500 miles per hour being
propelled by the interim cryogenic
propulsion stage
still quiet here on the loops of Mission
Control Houston teams are tracking no
issues during the trans lunar injection
burn
again this is about an 18 minute burn so
we have approximately 11 and a half
minutes left
it's also been one hour and 33 minutes
since liftoff today from Kennedy Space
Center that was a 1 47 a.m Eastern Time
launch
a smooth ride uphill as we heard from
Bruce tiller and Johnny Heflin working
with SLS at Marshall space flight center
and this view from Mission Control
Houston teams continuing to monitor the
Artemis 1 Mission this is where they
will be around the clock for the next 26
days all the way until we bring Orion
home for a safe Splashdown
coming up on seven and a half minutes
until into the translunar injection burn
so less than 11 minutes left in the burn
Orion now traveling at almost 20 000
miles per hour 251 237 miles away from
the Moon again that number continuing to
shrink
Orion itself is still over Earth
it is over the Pacific Ocean South of
Hawaii
as we've mentioned in today's coverage
multiple countries are represented in
Artemis 1 through the SLS Orion and
European service module as well as the
payloads riding along while NASA is
leading the Artemis Missions
International Partnerships will play a
key role in achieving a sustainable
presence on the moon while preparing to
send humans to Mars in 2021 over a dozen
countries signed the Artemis Accords
which will establish a common set of
principles to govern the Civil
exploration and use of outer space the
Artemis Accords will create a safe
transparent environment that facilitates
exploration science and Commercial
activities for all of humanity this
cooperation not only furthers space
exploration but also enhances peaceful
relationships between countries on Earth
we're now over nine minutes into the
translunar injection burn and 18 minute
burn so we have
about nine minutes left we're about
halfway through the rl-10 engine
continues to fire at maximum thrust
Orion traveling attached to the interim
cryogenic propulsion stage now over 20
600 miles per hour
it's been one hour and 37 minutes since
we launched today again that was 1 47
a.m eastern time from Kennedy Space
Center Orion is still attached to the
interim cryogenic propulsion stage this
is the last burn for the interim
cryogenic propulsion stage while
attached to Orion it will also have a
disposal burn later on
about 10 minutes after we have icps cut
off Orion will separate from the interim
cryogenic repulsion stage itself and the
capsule will be flying free still
attached to the European service module
we've got about seven minutes left in
the translunar injection burn Orion
traveling now at over 21 000 miles per
hour
the rl-10 engine continues to fire on
the interim cryogenic propulsion stage
powering the translunar injection burn
this is the second firing of the trans
or of the icps today the first we saw
was the perigee Rays maneuver which
lifted the lowest point of Orion's orbit
around the Earth and put it in the
proper positioning for this burn this is
the burn that commits us to the Moon
we're now over 12 minutes into this burn
again it's about an 18 minute burn so
less than six minutes left and one hour
39 minutes since we launched Orion and
the icps now traveling at over 21 400
miles per hour and as I promised we
continue to grow closer to the moon now
249 000 miles away
now over 13 minutes into the translunar
injection burn putting us less than five
minutes away from cut off we have had a
nominal burn so far that rl-10 engine
continues to fire at maximum thrust 25
000 pounds of thrust we're now traveling
over 21 730 miles per hour
and we've just heard the call for
Priority One meaning we have reached the
point at which we could return at lunar
return or similar speeds testing the
heat shield as required ahead of flight
for Artemis 2.
now over 14 minutes I know the trans
lunar injection burn less than four
minutes until cut off traveling now at
over 21 900 miles per hour
now less than three minutes away from
cut off of the interim cryogenic
propulsion stage and coming up on one
hour and 42 minutes into the Artemis One
mission the rl-10 engine on the interim
card identity propulsion stage continues
to fire as planned at maximum thrust
again this is about an 18 minute burn
that's about twice as long as the ride
to orbit today so that just shows how
much power we need to break free from
the pull of Earth and take us to the
Moon
foreign
16 minutes now into the translunar
injection burn Orion traveling at over
22
276 miles per hour
about a minute and a half now until cut
off of the interim cryogenic propulsion
stage again this being an 18 minute burn
we are now 248 280 miles away from the
Moon and continuing to grow closer
605 miles away from Earth and continuing
to increase that distance
less than a minute now until cutoff of
the icps
and the end of the translunar injection
burn we've had a good burn all the way
through so far
and one hour 44 minutes since launch
today
and we have cut off of the interim
cryogenic propulsion stage which has
committed Orion to the trans lunar
conjunction the spacecraft is Moon bound
Orion is now traveling at 22 500 miles
per hour 247
450 miles away from Earth
now that the interim cryogenic
propulsion stage has completed its
translunar injection burn it is no
longer needed to propel us to the moon
it's done its job and it will separate
from Orion after it separates those 10
cubesats we discussed will be deployed
from the Orion stage adapter which is
below the service module and above the
icps each payload will be ejected with a
spring mechanism from dispensers
installed on the Orion stage adapter and
again these will help us study the moon
and space weather test Innovative
propulsion Technologies analyze the
effects of radiation on organisms and
provide high resolution imagery of the
Earth and Moon the cubesat deploys will
start just short of about four hours
after launch once those cubesats are
deployed the icps will be on track for
disposal in a heliocentric orbit meaning
it will closely Circle the sun until
destroyed
the next change we'll see is for the
icps to separate from Orion and the
service module those will continue
flying free on their journey toward the
Moon
it's now been an hour 47 minutes and 30
seconds into the First Flight of the
Artemis program Orion now traveling 21
860 miles per hour
1129 miles away from Earth
that stage separation from the interim
cryogenic propulsion stage again should
be about 10 minutes after the translunar
injection burn is complete so
approximately seven minutes from now
shortly after icps separation Orion's
service module will fire its auxiliary
thrusters to move the spacecraft a safe
distance away from the expended stage
Orion continues on an outbound path to
the moon and the Ryan stage adapter
attached to the interim cryogenic
propulsion stage will deliver several
small payloads over several deployments
foreign
we're now over 1 hour 51 minutes since
launch today from these uh Kennedy Space
Center in Florida
Orion is traveling attached to the
interim cryogenic propulsion stage but
not for much longer we look for that
separation to happen in about five
minutes at that point Orion will still
be flying attached to the service module
and in this animation you can see the
service module directly below the
capsule those solar array wings are
deployed
the spacecraft now traveling over 20
5070 miles per hour
continuing to increase its distance from
Earth now over
1780 miles away continuing to decrease
its distance from the Moon 245
150 miles away
hearing confirmation from teams here in
Mission Control Houston that the solar
arrays are in their proper configuration
for interim cryogenic propulsion stage
separation again we just saw the
translunar injection burn a successful
approximately 18 minute burn that has
helped Orion break free from the pull of
Earth's gravity and sending us toward
the moon we're now standing by for
separation from that stage now that it
has done its job for Orion however it
still has a job to do it will help eject
some cubesats that will help us study
the Moon Earth and the space environment
Orion now traveling at 19 700 miles per
hour
2270 miles away from Earth
we're expecting that stage separation to
happen in about a minute
as you can see we have confirmation of
interim cryogenic propulsion stage from
Orion
with the Earth in the background and the
Moon is our destination Artemis
generation we are going
it's been one hour 57 minutes and 40
seconds since Orion launched Atop The
SLS from Kennedy Space Center in Florida
at 1 47 a.m eastern time after a smooth
ride to orbit a parody raised maneuver
and a translunar injection burn
conducted by the interim cryogenic
propulsion stage Orion is now flying
free attached to the European service
module and on its Journey To The Moon
that might be the end of today's
broadcast but the Artemis 1 Mission has
only just begun we'll continue live
coverage for major Milestones including
the outbound powered flyby and other
major Burns but when we're not live you
can check out
blogs.nasa.gov Artemis and the NASA
newsletter for updates on the spacecraft
we're also excited to introduce Artemis
all access it's a short video product
that will provide updates about Mission
accomplishments with a look at what's to
come as well as inside looks and
explainers about the mission and if you
want to stay updated on Mission
activities and how to watch Splashdown
you can still register as an online
Mission participant with NASA's Virtual
guest program to stay informed as the
mission progresses virtual Mission
participants for Artemis 1 will receive
curated resource and Mission activities
straight to their inbox you can register
at go.nasa.gov virtual artemis1 that's a
Roman numeral one as part of the URL
don't forget you can also learn about
the mission on NASA and Artemis social
media accounts we'll be holding a
post-launch news conference at Kennedy
Space Center at 5 a.m Eastern Time 4 a.m
central time and you can watch live at
nasa.gov live we'll also be back